Confidence to me was like how you feel about yourself.
So people want to feel great before they start anything.
And so what ends up happening is people don't actually take
action because they're waiting for their confidence to come.
The confidence part will come over time.
It will come with action, it will come with repetition,
it will come with gaining competence.
And so if we have radical confidence,
which to me means you don't allow your negative mindset,
the voice in your head that's saying, you're not worthy,
you're not good enough, you don't let it take over.
(soft upbeat music)
What's that mission?
What's that reason you get up every day?
Do I feel healthy?
Do I have a healthy mindset?
Am I proud of myself?
Do I get up every day and fight
for something bigger than myself?
If I can keep answering those as yes,
then I know I'm doing the right thing.
Hey everybody, how you guys doing?
Welcome to the podcast.
Today, we're gonna talk about self-confidence.
We're gonna talk about relationships, communication,
mindset and tons more with entrepreneur turned author
Lisa Bilyeu.
Lisa is the co-founder along with her husband
and friend of the podcast, Tom Bilyeu, of Quest Nutrition
which is a company she was instrumental in helping grow
into a billion dollar unicorn.
And she's also the co-founder and president
of Impact Theory Studios which is a digital first
media company where among many other duties,
she hosts a show called "Women of Impact",
which is all about empowering women to become the heroes
of their own lives.
And that theme is a theme that predominates in her new book
which is called "Radical Confidence".
It's a memoir/practical toolbox for developing
a growth mindset and transcending something that she calls
the purgatory of the mundane.
So if you're somebody who feels stuck in a life scenario,
maybe in a job, a career, in a relationship that isn't quite
serving you and you're looking for a constructive,
empowering way forward, then I think this one is for you.
Lisa is a delight, she's a absolute force of nature.
I really enjoyed talking to her,
so please hit that subscribe button and enjoy.
I'm really glad to have you here today.
It took a minute for us to get it together
but always delighted to be in your presence.
Congratulations on the new book,
there's so much stuff to talk about
and I just look forward to enjoying your energy.
I'm so excited, Rich, seriously.
So I know Tom a little bit and we've done
each other's shows and all of that kina stuff.
And one of the things that I always respect
and kinda admire about him is how quick he is to make sure
that you're part of any conversation around his success
and what he does.
You know he's always saying it's like,
it's Lisa and me, we're partners, we're equal partners.
Like you gotta understand where Lisa's coming from
and how much she's contributed to all of this.
It's very similar to the relationship that I have
with my wife in terms of kinda what we've built together
and individually.
And when you share that perspective with somebody,
you typically get that response of well,
behind every great man, there's a strong woman.
And like, I hate that.
My wife hates that
because it's still a very condescending perspective.
It means that the woman is standing behind the man.
It's so true and I used to be conflicted with it
because coming from a very traditional Greek background,
that was kinda what you were taught that is going to be
your identity.
So originally I actually was very proud of that.
And so as I would see Tom grow into the person he is today,
like I was very proud to feel like I'm behind the scenes
and I have his back and it's big help because of me.
But you are right over time, I started to realize actually,
it's kinda positioning me as being secondary.
Have you read "Rocket Fuel"?
Hm-hm.
So good.
So it basically explains how in most dynamics,
whether it's business or relationships,
you've got the one that's the more dominant,
the big shiny object, the one that has the,
basically the rocket, the beast and then you have the fuel
that is behind the rocket but without the fuel,
the rocket doesn't move.
And so, that book really allowed me to codify kinda mine
and Tom's relationship and feeling like
I am just as valuable.
And to your point of being behind the person,
it doesn't feel like that analogy makes you seem as equals.
And so the rocket fuel analogy was so perfect for me
when I heard it.
Right, what's interesting about the book is that
conservative, traditional perspective.
Like for many years there was a lot of pride
in I'm supporting Tom and that's my role.
I'm CEO of Bilyeu Industries.
Tom's going to work, I'm taking care of everything else,
like very traditional and obviously,
an outgrowth or a reflection of the way that you were raised
and a certain level of unapologetic pride about that.
But I feel like part of that growth equation for you or arc
has been stepping out from behind that shadow,
owning your own space and that's really
part of the whole narrative here.
Yeah, absolutely.
And as you were talking, I realized a big part of it was,
I didn't feel like I had the confidence
to be standing next to him.
And so it felt actually comfortable being behind him
feeling like the supportive wife because when you step out
in front and you own your thoughts, you own the way you act,
the way you show up every day, that can be very scary.
And when you don't have confidence, it actually deters you
from wanting to step out in front.
Yeah, and I think, when you address this in the book,
it's easy for people to look at you and Tom and see
this very successful, glamorous couple living
a certain kind of lifestyle and enjoying a certain level
of success and impacting a lot of people
while you're doing it and say,
well, that's just an inaccessible situation for me
to relate to.
They're who they are but I'm who I am.
And your book is really an attempt to like decode that
and deconstruct that and paint this picture of like
the truth and what was amazing was,
reading like, I've heard Tom talk about this like,
you don't understand how hard it was
and where we came from and all of that
but you really filled in the gaps on that.
Thank you.
'Cause it was a really hard fought long road
to get to where you guys are.
Yeah and that was a big part of why I wrote the book,
is so many people ask me Rich like,
my God, I want your confidence.
And I'm like A, you have no idea how I started,
I was that 14 year old girl that was just bullied
and teased for my looks and I was put in a special class
for being mildly dyslexic and holding my pencil
the wrong way.
And I felt really badly about my myself.
And so when people were saying to me now like,
oh my God, you're so confident.
I was like, I still don't feel it.
You should still hear the voice in my head
that is utterly negative on anything that I do.
And so to me that it was imperative to write a book
and call it "Radical Confidence" because to me it wasn't
the traditional way that people think of it.
I'm still scared, I'm still nervous, I still doubt myself
all the time but how do I keep showing up?
It's really to not listen to the negative thoughts,
it's to have a toolbox that you can dive into
when you don't feel great about yourself.
Like how do you pick yourself back up?
That's the thing that I really wanted to emphasize
in the book because to paint the vision of perfection,
doesn't serve anyone.
It doesn't serve me.
If I think I'm perfect, where's there to go?
Where's there to grow?
So it was very important to be so honest about
where I come from, how I still think
and I still have that negative voice that's telling me
I'm no good.
I just don't let it get in my way.
Well, we're gonna get to the growth mindset stuff
and the radical confidence stuff but let's set the stage
a little bit and fill in the gaps.
Walk us through your background a little bit,
growing up in this conservative Greek family in the U.K.
and coming to Los Angeles and meeting Tom
and kinda everything that ensued.
Yeah, I was a kid that had big dreams.
Like I was getting up at three in the morning
to watch the Academy Awards like as a kid in London
'cause I honestly, I loved movies.
It was an escape for me because I didn't feel great
about myself because I was teased
because girls weren't very nice to me in school.
I found movies to be such a beautiful way to escape
and to dream big.
And so as a kid, I was like, I wanna make movies,
I wanna make films.
And so I came to America, I do this film course
and my teacher happens to be my husband.
Now-
Well, let's hold on for a second.
Well, I wanna drill down a little bit more like-
Let's do it.
I love these stories of you in high school
like sneaking into movie premiers and all of that.
Like that's how far you took this.
And my sense of that is that, you were a dreamer
in the context of a family situation that was driving you
towards marriage, kids, something very safe, secure,
traditional, and was really muting that higher ambition
that you had like you had something that you aspired to
that extended beyond what was acceptable in your house.
Yes, thank you.
Actually, that's so on point and very important to mention
because as I was this kid that was having these big dreams,
watching movies, my dad was always telling me
that I would end up being a stay-at-home wife and now look,
he didn't mean that to be cruel.
He didn't wanna be mean but where he came from,
a tiny, tiny village in the mountains of Cypress
where literally, a toilet was a hole in the floor.
And so, because there were limited amount of kids
that could go to school in the village,
he was one of the chosen ones and he was a boy.
And so he just saw no woman ever got chosen
because there was no contraception.
So women didn't get chosen because they were gonna get
pregnant very early on anyway.
So that mentality, that idea, that notion is exactly
what my dad had and instilled in me growing up.
So when I wanted to have these big dreams,
I wanna go to America, I wanna make film.
All I got was, well,
you would end up being a stay-at-home wife.
And even to the point where I was this kid falling
on the floor, scraping my knee like as kids do,
yeah, my grandmother would come running over to me
and in her big thick hat and she like, oh, you'll be okay
by the time you get married, it's okay.
Think about that messaging.
Think about what that does to a little girl
over and over and over again.
That every time you are upset, every time you are hurt,
she comforts you with a notion that don't worry,
you'll be okay by the time you get married.
So really she's kinda setting the stage
as marriage being the end goal.
That's like the highlight of your life.
And even your dad going so far is to say,
when you were struggling in school to just sort of say,
well, it's not gonna be that big of a deal
because ultimately, you're just gonna end up being married
and it won't matter.
Yeah, I wanted to study film because I was like,
I wanna be a movie director, I've got these big dreams.
And so yeah, we argued for like two weeks
and in the end he was just like,
ah, it doesn't matter anyway, you'll be a stay-at-home wife.
Again, he didn't mean it to be malicious,
that was just his perspective.
But when I think about how we show up and who we become,
it really does I think stem from who we were as kids
and what we are told we are going to be.
So even though I had these big dreams,
my belief system overtook the dream that was inside me.
Yeah, so you come to LA to do this,
it's New York Film Academy, right?
Yeah.
I know that they have that summer program
'cause I looked into it for one of my kids
where you get to be on the back lot.
Yes.
At Warners, right?
Universal studios.
Oh, at Universal.
Yeah.
And it looks like a really cool program.
And I didn't know that like, so Tom was like the teacher?
Yeah, so what happened was I finished film school,
so I ended up going to film school 'cause my dad was like,
well, I'll study whatever you want,
it doesn't really matter.
So I go to film school and I didn't get the experience
in movie directing.
Now I had the dream, I was gonna be the first female
to win Academy Award as movie director.
Katherine Bigelow beat me to it but anyway,
so that was what I wanted to do,
so when I went to my dad after college and it cost money
'cause it was a private, four week, eight week course,
we argued and eventually he's like, all right,
let's just make a deal.
When you go there, when you come back,
you're going to get a job and be serious.
Now when he says get a job, it basically is a job
to tie you over until you get married.
Because then as soon as you get married,
the expectation is you quit your job and you have kids.
So when I had this course that I really wanted to go to,
he eventually said, yes.
I go to America, I think it's gonna be an eight week course
and I walk in and Tom is my teacher.
Right. (laughs)
I love how you describe him at that time.
It just seems so different than the Tom we all know.
Yeah, it really is.
And that's part of my story and our story
is that neither of us had growth mindsets when we met,
we had very different lives.
We came from very different backgrounds
and that was partly the big hurdle we had to get over
with my family where I was the first person in my family
to marry outside of the Greek culture.
And so all the pushback that we got from that
and then having a growth mindset and developing
to being the people we are today.
Right, hence ensues this long struggle where you guys
are just trying to make ends meet
and living in a tiny apartment and driving a beater car
and all the kinda stuff that happens when you're young
in Hollywood and have a dream.
But one thing that Tom always talks about
and I don't mean to be continuing to bring it back to Tom-
No, at all.
It's just my frame of reference.
It seems like he felt this obligation
or had made this promise like I'm gonna create a large life
for my wife.
And that was part of how he wins over your family
or your dad.
And that seems to really drive him like his commitment
to following through on that promise.
Yes, that is very true.
And that was kinda one of the early signs for me
that he was very special in my life.
So we wanted to get married.
He went to my dad to ask for his blessing
and my dad just said, no.
My dad came from a very traditional Greek family
so for him, he was like, well, first of all,
the cultures are different, how can this ever work?
What's gonna happen to your kids?
You're not even Christian,
you can't get married in a Greek church.
And my dad was seeing all the things
of why it wouldn't work.
And then Tom, yeah, his famous was-
Do you leave out the part about being an atheist?
He did leave it out, I was like,
babe, just don't tell my dad that.
But he was one of those people he said,
look, if this is important to you,
I'll absolutely get christened.
And it doesn't mean that you're changing my beliefs,
so if you can just respect that I still believe
in what I believe in.
But if this is important to you and so it was those moments
that showed who he was, the moments where he showed my,
he just said to my dad, I respectfully hear you
and thank you for giving me your opinion
but I still plan to ask your daughter to marry me.
Because my dad came from nowhere, like literally nothing
and he'd built his wealth and success.
A house roof over his head, that was what he saw in,
so he turned to Tom and he's like,
he don't even really have a job.
Like at that point Tom was part-time,
he was moving to England so that we could try
and be together or temporarily moving to England.
So my dad was like, you can't even support her,
how are you gonna take care of my daughter?
Very traditional.
And so Tom famously said, look, I know who you see today
may not be who you think I can become
but I know what I'm made of and I'm gonna show you one day
that I will take care of your daughter.
And all of this is without me in the room
but it was just the promise that he made to my dad.
And it was I think, a beautiful push for Tom as well.
He held onto that.
He held onto the doubt and it wasn't doubt in the cruel way,
it was just my dad just saw in essence, the facts,
it's like, you've got a part-time job.
You're not earning very much money.
You are in lots of college debt.
And my daughter has a roof over her head,
she's very comfortable and you're trying to take her away
across the world and I don't even know who you are
and because he couldn't relate to his culture
because Tom wasn't Christian and didn't have much
of a cultural background, my dad was just like,
this could never work.
Beyond that, the bullseye that you're aiming for
is like threading a needle that the success
that you aspire to alludes most people.
I mean, every year, busloads of people arrive in Hollywood,
they've got a dream of being in the movies and before long,
they're working some kinda part-time job or whatever
and most of them flame out and leave or just settle
into whatever career path is ancillary to the thing
that they really aspire to do.
And that really is the beginning of your path as well.
Like Tom ends up in some job, you're home prepping meals
and wondering what you're doing with your life
and that goes on for a long time.
Like I think people, if they Google you it's like,
oh, Quest and like this huge success story
but there was a lot of hardship during that period of time
of just making ends meet, of course, but also this idea
of you settling into this purgatory of the mundane
which is a big theme of the book.
Yeah, it was really hard and I think that's the thing
I try to lean into now more and more and talking about
because I never hit rock bottom.
And how many people have you seen or met in your life
that their successes came because they hit rock bottom?
Yeah, I can raise my hand right here.
Oh, right.
So right, it's like you've got nothing to lose,
so why not go for it?
But what about someone like myself who
I didn't hit rock bottom.
If you'd asked me the time and people did, oh, how are you?
Fine, I'm all right.
It wasn't exciting, nothing bad enough to jump me
into action and I stayed there for eight years
and that's why I call it the purgatory of the mundane.
It's like, you're this hamster just running on a wheel
and actually not going anywhere.
And so, because of that, I didn't think that I had the right
to ask for more because I didn't hit rock bottom.
And I'd had so many stories of other people
who had real hardships.
And so for the first couple of years
where you had said earlier, President of Bilyeu Enterprises
which basically was my title for being a stay-at-home wife.
Right, it's like a whitewashed-
It was, yeah.
A senior housewife.
Exactly.
So I used gratitude and I was like for the first year
we just doing this for the greater good.
Tom was gonna try and make enough money
so we could make movies.
So we kinda had a plan and so I was like,
okay, I can do it for the grade of good.
I don't like cooking, I don't like cleaning
but you know what?
I can do this for a year.
I can do this for 18 months.
And so, every time I would find myself unhappy,
miserable, thinking to myself,
how did I end up here when this wasn't the life I wanted?
I used gratitude to remind myself of,
I had an amazing husband, I had a roof over my head,
so many people don't.
Now year three, year four, year five, year six, year seven,
year eight, that gratitude is exactly what kept me stuck.
Yeah, it's a really interesting point that you make,
the downside of gratitude or how relying on gratitude
can prevent you from believing in something better
for yourself.
'Cause if you're always told to just be grateful
for what you have then you're gonna settle
or you're gonna be reluctant to reach for a higher place.
Exactly and that was exactly what happened to me
where I used it as an empowering tool,
which I think it can be beautiful so that you don't
just have a negative mindset all the time.
So shift in that perspective can be beautiful.
The problem was is that it stopped me
from ever then speaking up.
And so in year five and six where I was like,
this is not the life I wanted.
I was like, well, how ungrateful of you, Lisa?
Your husband is out every day working,
you don't have to work.
I'm cooking, I'm cleaning but I don't have to go
to a nine to five or anything like that.
How ungrateful are you?
How ungrateful are you to want more and say
that you are unhappy when you have a roof over your head,
when you have food to eat, other people don't.
And so that gratitude piece absolutely made me
stayed where I was and it didn't allow me to speak up
and say, hang on a minute.
Yes, I can be grateful for this.
I can absolutely be grateful for having a husband
that loves me and the roof over my head but that doesn't
and shouldn't dismiss this other side of it
where I'm profoundly unhappy.
Like why do we dismiss other areas of our lives
because we should be grateful for one area?
Yeah, I think this is the most accessible
and relatable aspect of your whole story.
I mean, I think there's millions of people out there
who are in some version of that reality
where everything's kinda okay and we can just perpetuate
the status quo, add in infant item
and maybe next year there'll be a promotion
or something like that and we can go on a vacation.
There's nothing inherently wrong
with anything that's happening,
it's not really the life that I aspire to have
but like who am I to aspire to that?
Like, I have it pretty good.
And without that bottom or that kinda intervening
interruption like an illness or something to shake you
out of your kinda daydream of the life that you're living,
it's hard to have the level of self-reflection
to make those changes.
Like I know all the positive changes that
I've made in my life have really been driven by pain
and that pain can be emotional, physical, existential,
but it has to reach a certain level of acuteness
in order to get my attention.
So it actually takes a stronger person and a lot more
kind of wherewithal to have your wits about you
to course correct when things aren't cataclysmic.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's why it's like,
it really did feel like it was purgatory.
It was like, I wasn't moving either way.
So what is the inflection point?
I mean, I know growth mindset enters stage left
and Tom starts to develop this interest
and you just start to do the same and that really begins
to shift the energy and the trajectory here but like,
how did that actually function?
Like what exactly transpired?
So we had been doing it for eight years,
eventually it turned into,
we were trying to make enough money to make movies
and then it just turned into just making enough money.
Right, that can become a delusion, right?
Like someday we're gonna make movies
but we gotta make the money first.
Or I went to law school and it was like,
well, I didn't go to law school so I could work
in a big corporate law firm but I gotta pay these loans off
and when I get enough money, then I'll end up
pursuing the thing that I actually wanna do.
Most people never get to that because they're so unhappy,
they start to overspend,
to compensate for their lack of happiness
until they're so leveraged that they're stuck in a situation
they never wanted to be in in the first place.
Yeah, it's so true and so like, to your point,
I literally say, oh, well, we'll do this when.
And oh, we'll do it when we have enough money,
when we have enough time, when I have the confidence,
there's always like, we'll do it when.
And so the thing that I'd love to ask your audience
right now is like, when are they looking at?
Well, the goal post always move because as soon as you get
close to that and it becomes a potential reality,
that's too frightening so we have to push it out again.
Yeah, that's fascinating.
That's so interesting, why do you think we do that?
I mean, because the fear of the unknown exceeds
like the discomfort of the current.
I think people are afraid of what would happen
if they actually put themselves on the line
and there's a certain comfort level in just continuing along
the current path and there's a level
of emotional self sabotage that I think certain people have.
I know what that feels like.
Yeah, 1000%, I love that.
So yeah, it was after eight years, we were doing the same.
It was like, oh, well, we'll do this-
Eight years.
Yeah, we'll do this when.
I'll speak up when.
When we have enough money then I'll be happy.
When my husband feels successful, he'll be happy
so then I'll be happy.
And so there was always the when and eventually
what happened was we would ended up chasing money.
And to me, I'd always made a commitment.
Like I was okay with actually being unhappy.
I wasn't okay with my relationship breaking.
And when I started to see that Tom's unhappiness
and my unhappiness was causing our relationship to fracture,
it almost gave me the jolt I needed to say,
hey, I don't care about money
like what the hell are we doing right now?
I've lost my husband, you don't seem happy.
I've lost who you are, your personality, I'm not happy.
So what on earth are we doing this for?
So let's just reassess what our life should look like.
And of course, surprise, surprise,
we tried to run away from the problem.
So it was like, oh, well, we'll just quit
and move countries.
That should be fine, we'll go to Greece and we'll just write
and we'll be happy.
And so in that process, Tom had these two business partners.
So for the eight years,
they were trying to make enough money, build a company
and so eventually he's like, all right, I'll go in and quit.
And on paper, we had earned a couple of million dollars
but we were both of the mindsets if you don't cross
the finish line, you don't get the payout.
We weren't willing to cross the finish line.
And so that was one of those moments where it's like,
oh, money doesn't buy happiness.
Well, they kept saying
they were gonna sell the company, right?
And that kinda dragged along and kept you in it
longer than you wanted to be because that never happened.
And it wasn't until, didn't didn't you guys decide,
okay, Tom's gonna quit, he goes into quit
and then it was one more thing like, okay,
well now we're gonna reconfigure.
Six more months and then we're gonna change the way
we're doing things and we're gonna try this other thing.
Yeah, the difference in that situation,
so after the eight years, we finally had the talk,
this isn't good for our relationship,
what's the point in success if you're not happy?
We're chasing money.
On paper, now got a couple of million dollars
that we've helped build this other company
and yet we are the most unhappy we've ever been.
So the change was to go in and quit and finally he did.
And that was the pivot where he went in,
told his business partners and they admitted
they were unhappy too.
And so in that, they said, okay,
now we've at least been honest with each other,
we need to come up with a path and a strategy to get out.
So they put, they said, okay,
let's give ourselves six months
and because they had made the change of actually discussing
their unhappiness, I really did think,
okay, this was different.
And so they were just in for the next six months,
we're gonna try actually sell the company
and we're gonna build another company that's predicated
on passion, desire and a mission.
Right and that meant we're gonna make these nutrition bars
even though there's a bazillion other nutrition bar brands
out there, like that's gonna be our ticket?
Yeah, I think there was like 1500 protein bars
on the market and someone in the field actually said,
there's 1500 bars, we need another bar,
like we need a hole in the head.
So that was a feedback we got when we had the idea.
So as the Greek wife, I was like,
babe, how can I support you?
You're on this new venture, I'm so happy for you,
you actually seem excited because my mom and his mom
were clinically obese.
And so Tom's like, babe, I can get up every day
and fight for my mom.
Like I can fight for her to help on this health journey.
And so, that's why it was very important for him
to really kinda go all in.
So I said, okay, as your wife, how can I help?
And so as they were trying to sell this tech company
on the side, they're like,
okay, well you're the only one that's free,
do you mind just shipping a couple of bars
from the living room floor?
And then it was like, well, you're free,
do you mind just like weighing some ingredients?
Well, you're free, do you mind just go?
And so it just kept being like, well, you're free,
do you mind helping out because no one else was available.
And so in that, in shipping bars from my living room floor,
having to figure out how I go to the post office
and mail a hundred boxes instead of four,
every step of the way, these tiny little things
I had these bumps and these hurdles and these obstacles
and in those moments where the old Lisa would've been like,
well, I don't know what I'm doing.
I better not do it because I have no confidence,
'Cause our house was up for collateral,
in those moments, I was like, all right,
you can actually not do it and lose your house Lisa
or you can figure it out.
Right, it's accidental entrepreneur.
It was, it was so, yeah.
It's sort of like, all right,
well, what's the problem we have to solve today?
It's not like we're building a billion dollar company.
It's like, I need to figure out how to get these bars
wrapped in packaging and shipped to this certain place.
At the same time, I'm interested in like what happened
to the whole movie thing?
Like, so is this still like a vehicle to making movies?
Like we're gonna do this bar company
and we're just pushing the goal posts out
on the movie thing or did that get supplanted
by the kinda excitement and joy and level of engagement
that came with like building a company that you cared about?
Yeah, I think it was one of those moments
where it was like, okay, we wanted to make movies as kids,
we really loved the idea, we met,
we definitely dreamt about it.
We had both though worked on movie sets
when we first got married.
Yeah, it's not what you think it's gonna be.
It was not what you thought.
I had an actor throw a matchbox at me.
I mean, like actually threw a matchbox at me and I was like,
does this really happen?
Like you kinda hear about it in Hollywood
but you don't actually think it's actually gonna happen.
And Tom had just an equally bad experience on a movie set.
And so, both of us were just like, we weren't willing
to be disrespected.
Like it's not the world we come from.
And so I was like, I don't know if I want this dream
of working on these film sets where people can easily
just disrespect you depending on what your title is like,
that just didn't feel right to me.
And so that's where the crazy idea from Tom was like,
well babe, we should just make enough money
so we can make our own movies.
And that way we hire our own team
and no one can disrespect each other.
Seemed like an easy naive thought when we first got married
but as we then started to chase the money
and that evolved into absolute unhappiness,
after those eight years, we just sat down and said,
what would actually bring us happiness?
Like if it's not movies because right now to make movies,
especially how we were dreaming, the big budget,
it was just, it wasn't feasible.
We would have to keep chasing money.
And we saw where that led.
And so in that moment it was like,
what is actually going to fill our heart?
What is actually going to help us feel alive again?
And it was in that discussion which then led Tom to protein
so his business partners,
all had like their own selfish desires, we call it, right?
One of the guys was obsessed with nutrition
and the other guy was just obsessed with working out.
And so Tom was just like, his own reason,
he could get behind it to fight for his mom.
And when you have a mission like that that is so tied to you
when you've been chasing money for so long,
he was just like, babe, this makes me feel good
about myself.
This makes me be able to face the things that
I'm not good at and be able to push myself to be better.
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world
is populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling profits on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium by which
to share their stories, which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change Volume II".
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Rich Roll Podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change" was a beautifully
rendered book worthy of display on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition by showcasing
even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets and physically interact
with the life changing ideas contained with them.
"Voicing Change Volume II" available now while supplies last
for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
So you guys have been together a long time.
About to celebrate our 20 year wedding anniversary.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so I've been with my wife
a little over 20 years at this point,
so I know what that feels like.
Yeah, it's amazing.
But in the story you just told, like what I hear
and what kinda recurs throughout the book
and every time I listen to you talk and Tom talk
is a level of intentionality that you bring
to your relationship.
Like there's a very conscious, deliberate, persistent effort
to come together and communicate very clearly,
what are we doing?
What do you want out of life?
What do I want outta life?
What are we doing on a daily basis?
That's furthering that like, there's an honesty and I think
when you're with somebody for 20 years,
it's easy to kinda go on autopilot and every relationship
ebbs and flows and has its peaks and valleys, et cetera
but it feels like that's very top of mind
and like Tom says like, the most important thing in my life
is my relationship with my wife and the kind of level
of intentionality that you bring
to that kinda communication,
I think is really interesting and rare.
So like pause on the timeline a little bit
and like drill down on that.
I'd love to.
So growing up, I just saw couples relate to each other
and they seemed like,
especially couples that had been together for a long time,
there was a lot of contentment I just saw
in so many different couples and animosity and slight,
what's the word where you like this sliding like
negative comments at each other like-
Right, like little passive aggressive.
Passive aggressive comments, yeah.
And I just thought like, it didn't sit well with me,
even as a kid, I was like but don't you guys
love each other?
Like don't you wanna be nice to each other?
Obviously, being naive and just kinda having that like
blanket statement in my head but when Tom and I met,
my parents were divorced and so were his.
And so, we just had the honest conversations
like neither of us want to end up like our parents.
And what did that mean?
And I kept hearing people saying,
well, relationship shouldn't be work.
And even that didn't set well with me 'cause I was like,
hang on a minute, do you think a business,
if you want to grow a business, a successful business,
do you think you have to spend time energy on that business?
I was like, yes.
So then why wouldn't a relationship be that?
Why don't you think of it like it is a business
in the sense of, is it always thriving?
And if it's not, what do you have to do differently?
And so, that really set the stage for both of us to say,
okay, we both know where we want to go
and now it's about figuring out have to get there
because we wanna be married for the rest of our lives
but happily married for the rest of our lives.
So we just created over time, rules of engagement
in our relationship.
So for instance, number one,
we never joke about divorce ever.
We call it the D-word in the family.
It's like Voldemort.
Like you can't say the word in the household
because we don't even joke about it
because we don't want that subliminal messaging
to get in each other's minds.
Non-negotiables, I have two non-negotiables
that I said to him from the beginning.
I said, if you ever cheat on me
or if you ever lay a finger on me like abusively,
I will be out the door and just to set him up for success
because I want the relationship to succeed,
I said, babe, just to be clear, there's no discussing it.
If either of those two things happen,
I will pack my bags and I will be out the door
before you have time to give me a reason.
So just bear that in mind.
Right, like it became this set each other up for success
because we both want this relationship to work.
Right and how do you maintain that over time?
Because it's one thing to set that straight upfront
but then as the years go by and life takes over
and you're busy and it's all about the businesses
and the things that you're creating.
It's pretty easy to let that slide as a priority.
Not that you forget about it but maybe it doesn't get
the attention that it did in your first couple years
of marriage.
Yes, you're so right.
So we actually worried about that.
So we sat down and said, okay,
what's the responsibilities we own in this relationship?
And what I mean by that is I have a better radar
that me and my husband aren't spending quality time together
quicker than he does.
Now so just like in a business, right?
Where you're like someone, I'm very good at logistics,
my husband's not good at logistics at all.
So when it comes to business,
when there's something needed for logistics, he comes to me,
there's no ego involved, there's no nothing, he's like,
I know that you're better so even if I disagree with you,
you're the responsible party.
And so we have that like in our relationship,
who's the responsible party that when we start to feel like
we are not connecting, who's better at it?
And so I said, I am.
So we made an agreement, okay.
Then I'm never gonna abuse it, I'm never gonna just do it
for any reason but if I do say, hey, babe,
we need to spend time together, he will reciprocate.
He won't push back, he won't say, what do you mean?
We just spent time together.
He will trust that I'm the responsible party to do that.
And so we've just come up with negotiations it's like,
okay, so if I say this, I need you to reciprocate
because let's face it, if you do that and you keep getting
someone saying, no, no, what do you mean? No.
Eventually you just give up.
So I said to him, for me to be encouraged to do this,
you need to reply with this phrase,
with this way of thinking and thank me
because I don't wanna feel like I'm fighting
for our relationship and I don't wanna feel like you're not.
So we came up with language that we use.
We come up with ways to engage each other so for instance,
I know Tom's terrible at his calendar
and so if I want a date night, I don't take it personally
that he doesn't think about it.
I just actually make sure that it gets done.
So I go to his assistant, I say, hey, I need time with him
at this time, for this many hours, please make that happen.
And then Tom will look at his calendar and he will turn up
with a smile on his face.
For all of this doesn't happen by accident
and that was the key.
And even in our relationship when it came to
because we have grown two businesses together,
you can imagine that sometimes gets a bit messy.
Sure. Yeah I mean, I know what it's like to collaborate
with my wife to build something professionally.
And for the most part, it's a tremendous joy
and I think that some of our parts exceeds
our individual roles and there's something really beautiful
to be celebrated and all of that.
And then we kinda go into our separate corners
and create our own stuff and that's a cool thing too
but I know all too well, how tricky it can be
when you're working together and living together
where work bleeds into your personal life.
There's no real boundaries.
Boundaries is a big theme theme in the book.
Like how do you set those healthy boundaries?
And then everything, all the communication
becomes sort of transactional about shipping
or whatever like whatever it is with your business,
you know what I mean?
So it's like, you're out to dinner and you can't talk about
anything other than the thing that you both care about
which is this business that you're trying to build.
And before it, the relationship is withering on the vine.
It's so true and we felt that.
And look, everything that I'm saying now is we've had
all of those issues.
And so, every time we have that moment where I'm like,
my God, we go to dinner, what we do is talk about work.
It's like, okay, wow, we've slipped back into this,
what am I gonna do differently next time?
And so, I do a lot of that.
It's like, what are the things we're going to do
when we start to see ourselves getting
into an unhealthy pattern?
Because I don't beat myself up or us up
for falling into certain traps.
I just pride myself on being the person that notices it
and then acts in accordance.
So for instance, Tom has a different threshold than I do
on his work, how much he works.
He works like 120 hours a week.
Literally I count, over the last eight months, it's insane.
I don't, I can't, I have health issues.
So here I am knowing I can't work that much.
He does and I'm an equal business partner.
So for me, it was really hard to not feel guilty
about switching off.
Or for him to feel resentful that you're not pulling
your weight?
Yes, so we have to talk about that.
So it's like, this is the life you want,
I do not want to be working 120 hours.
So we sit down, we have these discussions.
And then it's respecting each other's perspectives,
coming up with a strategy that makes sense for both of us,
for the business and for our personal.
So then it becomes, how do you maintain that?
Because it's one thing to say it, right?
To sit down, have a discussion, it's like, okay, I hear you.
And then to actually keep that going a month, two months,
three months down the line.
So for me, I get very tactical, I'm all about tactics
'cause I can get in my own head.
So I came up with an idea,
have you ever been to a Brazilian restaurant?
Where they do like the meat
and you have like this little swivel thing?
Behind like photo to shower-
Yeah, yeah.
In a past life.
Like I've been vegan for a long time.
Pre-yes, I have been to that place.
Okay, so we go to this place and it's got
this little thing that flips.
So it's like, you want meat, you don't want meat
and it's just an indicator.
So as I'm sitting there trying to think about,
what's an indicator to let Tom know
when I've stopped working 'cause he would come to me
when I'm in my self care time because of my health issues,
I would want to decompress.
And then he would walk in the room and tell me
this business problem.
And so I was like, this isn't gonna work.
We started arguing, I started getting upset.
Like you need to respect my boundaries and he's like,
but I don't know because I'm still in work mode.
So I was like, what can I do?
And I was like, oh, just like those Brazilian restaurants.
I was like, I need an indicator to show you babe
when I'm working and when I'm not.
So I came up with a goal where when I would be
in my bedroom, I had the lamp.
And so I was like, when the lamp is on babe,
it means that I'm in personal time.
If the lamp isn't on, then it means you can still talk to me
about work.
So the very next day he walks in the room he's like,
hey babe, sees the light and he's like, good to see you
and he walks back out of the room.
Things like that, it helps you both navigate situations,
respect each other's boundaries because if you believe
your partner wants some great for you, then you have to help
them understand the boundaries and when you set them,
help them guide them into how they can respect them.
Right, clearly defined, precise boundaries that are set
prophylactically before the crisis moment.
Correct.
And I think what happens with a lot of people
is there's an expectation of mind reading that happens
and then like an aggravation
when the mind isn't properly read.
But I think the real jujitsu move here is the ability
to have those conversations in a non-reactive mode.
Like it seems like you're both really good at that
because everybody has their buttons installed
by their histories and their upbringings
and stuff like that and you can say like,
we need to be able to talk about these things
but one phrase that comes out wrong and the other person
set off and then before it, you're off to the races,
down the rabbit hole of some kinda fight.
So clear communication, dispassionate communication
and the ability to pause when agitated because I'm sure
you or him say something that is provocative to the ears
of the other person, the ability to sit with that
and cogitate on it for a moment before responding
and it seems like you're both really good at that.
Like that's a skill and I'm interested in whether
that's an outgrowth of the work that you've done
on the growth mindset stuff or whether that's something
that you learned in a therapeutic context.
Because I think mastering that is really the key
so that the other person could be heard,
you can take that in, you can see it from their perspective.
You're not just spontaneously reacting,
looping some old behavior pattern that's gonna lead you
down a dark alley.
Yeah I mean, look, it's been falling on the floor,
messing up, having massive arguments the last days
and days and days and then coming to these conclusions
where we come up with a solution.
So it was never, even now, it's usually messy at first.
It's usually a problem arises,
we start to have some friction.
I sit back and I'm like, why do we keep having friction?
And then it becomes an assessment,
so the process is now quite easy for me in the sense of,
oh, the red flag, I noticed this red flag,
there's some friction here, what does this friction mean?
Why does it keep happening?
What is the behavior that both of us keep showing
where we keep showing up like this?
And then know with no judgment, sitting together,
being able to be honest with each other
because we know that we've got the same goal in mind
to have a happy, long lasting relationship
so we need to be honest with each other
and then hearing each other out and then finding a solution.
Now the solution part sometimes is 10 different ideas.
It's the lamp idea was like one of many
where we just kept arguing.
I was like, please, you need to respect my boundaries.
And so, eventually it was like, oh, okay,
here's a simple solution.
And so we kinda rinse and repeat, it becomes like,
notice the problem, come up with a solution
and everything is with no judgment.
Like that's super important to know that anytime
that we argue or there's any friction,
the very first thing I ask myself is, does he love you?
Like that's literally the first question I ask
because if he loves you and he wants good things for you,
then what is happening right now is not deliberate.
And so if you know it's not deliberate then to me,
it allows me to go into that conversation emotionally sober,
meaning that I don't, I'm not upset, I'm not frustrated,
I'm not taking it personally.
Ad then when you can enter conversations
where you're emotionally sober, I think that that's where
the best communication comes and then the last part
is making sure you just define words so that every time
you come together, you are using the words that the person
can hear not the words that you think you mean
and the other person doesn't hear them.
Yeah, that's a really important one.
And that's a conversation that I have with my wife
all the time.
She'll say something and I'll get upset
and then I'll have to say, I know what you meant was this,
what I heard was this because of how I interpret that.
But sometimes it has to go sideways a little bit
before you can right the ship.
And I think there's this idea that if you're in a healthy
marriage that's fruitful, that you're never gonna fight
and I just think that that's ridiculous.
Like I my wife and I fight, we don't fight all the time
but we fight and our rule is like,
we just stay in it until we get to the other side
like no one storms out of the room,
no one gets the right to end it in the middle of something
until we've sat in the discomfort and figured our way
out of it to some kind of conclusion
that we're both content with.
And I love that because you guys have had that discussion
and that agreement, meantime I'm the opposite.
And that's really because of me, not 'cause of him,
he's like cute, he's like, nope, we're not leaving,
we gotta solve this, we've gotta do and he'll spent hours
and hours and hours and I'm just exhausted
and emotionally drunk.
Like I'm just like, my emotions are all over the place,
I can't think straight.
Sometimes you need to take a break, regroup, come back.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But you have to come back, you can't just let it linger.
Right, exactly.
So that's all about having those discussions.
So first of all, he thought it was disrespectful
initially where he's like,
I can't believe you just walked off.
And so it was about having the discussion of why I needed
to walk away.
I'm like, babe, I can get it very heated and I know
I can let my emotions take over and so we both know
that doesn't serve this situation, right?
If we can agree me being hotheaded and saying something
that I'm gonna regret doesn't serve us.
Okay, if we can agree on that, how about
you just let me walk away but trust me, it is to calm down,
it is to emotionally regulate so that I can come back
and actually have the discussion that you wanna have
because you don't necessarily wanna have
an emotional discussion.
You wanna have a very logical discussion, right?
Like emotional, I can't have a logical discussion
when I'm emotional.
So instead of beating myself up or judging myself,
we came up with, okay, maybe.
So now, he's like, babe and I'm like, babe,
I have to walk away and he's like, okay baby.
And so I walk away but then what you do when you walk away
is also imperative to know, right?
You don't just wanna go and stew even more
or call your friend who is like,
yeah, I can't believe he said that to you and she just like,
or he just winds you up even more.
So that's like the other part of like,
what do you do when you actually walk away?
For me, it's reminding myself how he feels about me.
So your husband loves you?
Okay, so that's number one.
Do you think he deliberately tried to hurt you? Number two.
And then I just kinda like ask myself these questions
to orient me back to the intention.
You're also a much more heart centered person
than I think Tom is and I say that with great affection
for Tom but what's funny in the conversations
that I've had with him is sort of a weird kinda curiosity
that he has about spirituality
because it's sort of confusing to him, I think
and he's somebody who really lives in his head
and has been very successful problem solving in his head.
And I think is curious about what it would mean to move down
towards the heart a little bit but can't quite make
that connection or is kind of struggling to do that
and you seem to be more comfortable in that place.
I mean, a big part of the book is about intuition
and stuff like that.
And so, is that a source of disagreement with you guys
like you just mentioned a fight where he's trying to solve
it intellectually and sometimes you can't do it that way.
And when you're coming from a very different place
in terms of how to problem solve,
sometimes that can cause problems.
But also I think those polarities make for a very
interesting and compelling marriage.
I mean, my wife is much more heart centered
and spiritual than I am and thinks
I'm overly intellectualizing everything.
Whereas like a lot of dudes think I'm too much
on the spiritual side.
So, anyway, it's very true and here's the thing again,
it's like, that's the man that I married, I love him for it.
And I know how big his heart is.
I mean, he has like a lot of emotional moments.
When we are in these moments of discussion or arguments,
he doesn't have the emotion.
And so, that has been a hurdle that we've had to overcome
in that neither of us are right or wrong, right?
It's just, how do we communicate though in those moments
where I am absolutely talking from the heart
and he's very intellectual
and I perceive his intellectuallness, if that's even a word,
I perceive that to be heartless.
And I used to.
And so what I realized was,
oh, that was just how he processes things
and when I come to him emotional, he goes into fix it mode.
And like, I've heard a lot of my friends
or couples do right?
Where the female usually wants to be heard
and the guy normally wants to fix it.
That's the paradigm.
Yeah and so what we said is like,
okay, the truth is neither of us are right or wrong,
so instead of judging each other be like,
I can't believe you don't wanna hear me out
and it's just like, why it's not that I'm right,
it's just not what I need right now.
And so how as a couple do you maneuver through that?
And so for us, it was agreeing to the process
of if I come to him emotional that he has the responsibility
to stop me and say, baby, do you need me to listen
or do you need me to fix it?
And because I'm too emotional, I can't even think about
asking him myself that question.
So he's the responsible party to stop me, ask that,
it actually pauses me and I go, hmm, let me think.
I need you to just listen
and so his entire demeanor changes.
He sits down, he softens, he puts his hand on me
because I've told him what I need.
In those moments, I need you to touch my knee.
Again, we said earlier, right?
They're not mind readers.
So what do you need in those moments
so your partner can be there for you?
You have to articulate them and so,
my husband used to want to like,
gimme a big hug and like stroke my back and I'm like,
it's too much, I just need to put your hand on my knee.
And so now this is exactly what he does.
And so, I'm feeling the love that he's trying to give.
And he's able to show up for me and then vice versa.
When he's frustrated, he doesn't want me to like
or if he feels like he's on his knees
like he's really been crushed by something,
he doesn't want me to get down on my knees with him.
He wants me to metaphorically reach out my hand
and pull him back up.
And so knowing that he doesn't want that
when he's forced to his knees, I know how to act
and I know what to say to him that is what he needs
in that moment so it allows me to show up for him.
Yeah, that's great advice.
I mean, it all tracks back to having a level
of communication where all of that is made clear
in a safe place so that there is an understanding.
Yeah, exactly.
So even when it comes to triggers,
I'm very open with my triggers and so I say to him,
babe, you've just triggered me but now here's the thing.
I think just because he's triggered me,
it's not on him to solve the trigger, it's on me.
And so, this has been a recent thing that we've been doing
actually over the last like year, year and a half.
I've been more comfortable admitting my triggers.
I've been more comfortable talking to him about them.
And then in those moments I've said to him,
I recognize this as me and I'm working through it.
Like I'm actually less triggered now than I used to be
but I'm not there yet.
And so while I'm still working on my triggers,
do you mind just helping not use that word?
This is a me thing but you are really helping me.
And now it becomes almost setting boundaries
with respect and helping each other get over the problems
that they're having.
And so, even though that word for him, he's like
he may throw out left right and center not realize,
I will just articulate him.
Please don't use that word and if he does,
I'll just say, look, babe, I know you didn't mean to
but you just used that word, it really is triggering me
right now if you don't mind just holding off and he's like,
okay, well, it's habit.
I said, I totally get it,
maybe try and use this word instead.
And if he still gets it wrong, I still encourage him,
that's the thing it's like,
babe, I really do see you trying.
Get to see him say the word and then like stop himself
and so, you wanna encourage your partner.
And so, that's kinda the nuances of how we communicate,
again, having certain words, like the word important.
I use that word maybe three times a year.
So if I said to Tom, right now, if I've got on my phone,
I was like, hey, babe, it's important that you literally
get in the car right now and you drive to Rich Rolls.
He wouldn't ask why he would leave the meeting,
drop everything and jump in the car and get here.
And part of that is because you don't cry wolf with it?
Exactly, 100%, that is so imperative.
You don't cry wolf with it.
And you really wanna show up for your partner,
you hope that your partner wants to show up for you.
So having those levels of communication,
especially when you work together
because having communication on when you're talking to them
as a business partner versus a spouse is actually
very different.
So even with me calling him like right now,
if I called him and he was in a meeting,
he won't answer my first call.
If I called him again, he was in a meeting,
he won't answer my second call 'cause he's like,
it's a business thing, I'm busy.
If I call him a third time, he answers.
Now the reason why is, the third time means I'm calling you
as my wife and I need you.
And that's understood.
And that is completely understood.
Now the funny thing is, this is one of those stories
or moments where I called him I was, do you wanna actually,
if I share an intimate story?
Sure.
So I've had a lot of gut issues and it was early days
and I was hiding it from everybody, Tom obviously knew.
And I was in the middle of a photo shoot and my gut issues
would literally get me to the point
where I couldn't breathe, I can't stand up
and it happened in the middle of a photo shoot.
So I ran upstairs in my house, fell to my knees
on the floor, clutching my stomach and I was like,
I need my husband, I need my husband.
And so I call him once, I know he is not gonna answer.
I call him twice, I know he is not gonna answer.
I call him a third time and he doesn't answer and I'm like,
we've had this agreement, I can't believe he doesn't answer.
And so, I'm on my knee saying, oh my God, I need my husband,
I need my husband.
And in that moment I was like,
well, I can't stay on the floor.
And then I realized, oh my God, I don't need him.
I want him but I don't need him.
And in that moment, I was like, Lisa, you are your own hero.
Get the F up and be the hero of your own life.
Now I did get up and that was the moment that I realized
I would turn to my husband because I felt like I was weak
without him.
And that was the moment that I realized I'm actually
really strong and I can stand next to him.
Now in that story at the end, Tom came running to me
'cause he saw the three missed calls and he was so horrified
because his identity is of the husband that shows up.
And even to this day, Rich, I wrote that story in my book
and when he read it, he burst into tears and he said,
I can't believe I wasn't there for you.
That's how much our agreements mean to us.
And obviously we've had to work through it but I'm like,
babe, that was one of the most beautiful moments,
I'm glad you didn't answer the phone because it taught me
what I was made of and that I choose you, I don't need you
and that's actually even more beautiful.
But even today it still stings him.
Well, I think you have to be allowed to fall in order
to find your strength, right?
Like if there's always a net to pick you up,
then you're always on some level dependent
on something external.
Yeah, exactly.
And you never really developed the facility to grow
into your own power.
So it was meant to be, right?
It was, yeah but he still has that emotional thing
'cause he's like, we've agreed on this.
We pinky swore, we said we would always do this.
And I was like, but baby, it allowed me to see
what I was made of and that's so important to me,
to who I am today, that story is stuck with me so much
that I don't want him to take it away from me
but we've had to talk through it because I still know
that it stings him.
Do you find, well, let me say this.
I have found that when I'm under duress or my wife
and I are under duress financially, professionally,
or there's a lot going on or things aren't going great.
That is sort of a reminder to me to double down
on a lot of tools that we've developed
to foster our relationship and grow closer
and we survived like a pretty gnarly period of time
of financial dismantling that I think would've exploded
most relationships but in in fact, it brought us closer.
But my weakness is that when everything's good,
I'll take the foot off the gas, right?
So success can create a laziness
or a level of kind of entitlement.
And that's kind of what's up for us right now.
It's like, everything's going really good
and I've got this thing, my wife has another thing
and without a lot of conscious intentionality,
we can be ships in the night and I need to be reminded
like that's a recipe for a disaster.
Like we need to make sure that and in our relationship,
my wife is also the one who's like, hey, listen,
we need to get together, like this can't go on like this
forever or we're gonna have a problem.
We don't have a problem right now
but if we wanna not have a problem
we need to prophylactically like deal with this now.
And I rely on her for that messaging because I will be
the guy who's just, everything's good, we don't have to.
What's, you know?
And I'll do that in sobriety as well.
So my question I guess is, now that you guys are like
really successful, does it become more difficult to work
on these things because externally everything looks great
or 'cause it doesn't strike me like that.
It feels like you're still very intentional about staying
on top of all of this stuff
regardless of what's going on externally.
Yeah, I really am and I wrote about this in my book
where the phrase, this too shall pass.
I used to use that as a way to get me out of the dark days
when I wasn't feeling great,
when something wasn't going great.
Okay, Lisa, don't worry, you're not gonna stay here forever,
this too shall pass.
And I actually realized the most beautiful thing.
It also applies to the amazing days.
Like we kind of think that when something's great,
that's our baseline so we're like, oh, we're all good.
And I actually love the beauty in thinking,
well, this too shall pass and it's not to like bring fear
into your life, it's to actually go, let me just enjoy it,
let me pay attention.
Let me make sure that I'm actually soaking this in
because this isn't going to be the way all the time.
And so, I kind of love the ebb and flow because without
the amazing days, it allows, oh sorry, on the bad days,
it allows you to remember that it won't always stay
like that and it can be beautiful.
And then on the beautiful days,
reminding yourself that you know what?
You may actually be in rocky waters in your relationship
in a month or two, so actually embrace right now,
take it in, soak it in, enjoy it and then move on.
But that's very, it is intentional.
And I think to me, it is all about making sure
you are always speaking each other's language
no matter how busy, no matter how good things are
or how bad things are, always speak in that language.
So knowing your love language for me with Tom
is acts of service because he is so busy
and that's changed over time, he never used to be that.
But now over the last eight months,
he's been working 120 hours a week, I need it.
And then, so I just lean into it it's like,
hey, I really need you to show me with your time.
And so 'cause he could do, send me a lovely text
but it's not the language that I need right now.
And so, being open with each other in so many moments
is gonna be important and then always showing up.
So even on the great days he boils my kettle for me
so that when I wake up in the morning,
I can have a cup of tea or coffee.
He does that when it's really bad
and things aren't going great in our relationship
or in our business and he does it on the amazing day.
So making sure that you are always kinda thinking
of each other no matter what and doing these little things
but these little things you have to discuss
because if you don't know what they are,
you're not able to do them.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome
but I wanna snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plant Power Meal Planner.
Our affordable all in one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable, super delicious
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com
and right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again that's meals.richroll.com, promo code, RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
So back to Quest, you're in the shipping department,
you tell the story of like the bars spilling all over
the place and having to solve all of these little problems
and figuring out as the company grew and grew very quickly
like how to master at least this one kind of aspect
of the overall business and then having to pivot
into the media and kind of marketing side of things
and the intimidation, the lack of confidence,
the sort of all right, getting thrown in and sink or swim
sort of situation, which brings up the broader conversation
and theme of the book and title of the book
like "Radical Confidence".
Like what is, like what does that mean?
What is the difference between confidence
and radical confidence?
How does this fit in with growth mindset?
Like help me decode this language a little bit.
Yeah, absolutely.
So confidence to me was like how you feel about yourself.
So people want to feel great before they start anything.
I was the same.
I was, oh, I'm gonna start my YouTube channel
once I have the confidence.
And so, what ends up happening is people don't actually
take action because they're waiting for their confidence
to come and I joke about it in the book.
But it's like, if you want the glue to still,
you won't go to the gym, do a couple of reps
and think that you are all done, right?
It's kinda like with confidence,
it's like you have to keep practicing,
it takes some works.
Takes some action.
Exactly.
And so, the very first part that I say is, okay,
identify what you want confidence in,
to do what with the confidence?
Because we are all focusing on feeling good
but actually what do you want to achieve?
Usually people will say,
I want confidence to tell my boss I want a pay rise.
I want the confidence to tell my partner in my relationship,
I'm not happy.
I want the confidence to tell my parents,
I no longer want to study biochemistry
and I wanna be a standup comedian.
So it's usually something to do something with and I'm like,
great, now you know the end goal.
Now you've identified the end goal,
now you need to come up with a set of tools, stepping stones
to get to that goal because the confidence part
will come over time, it'll come with action.
It'll come with repetition.
It'll come with gaining competence.
The confidence is the byproduct.
And so, if we can stop focusing on the confidence
and have radical confidence which to me means
you have insecurities, you have doubts in yourself,
you actually probably are not equipped
for what you are about to do but you still show up
and do it anyway.
Now I don't mean blindly believing in yourself,
I don't mean blindly saying, ah, forget the fear
and do it anyway.
No, no, no, when you've got the fear you need,
to me, I needed stepping stones that were binary.
Okay, I wake up today.
Did I do this? Yes or no.
So some people, for instance, let's take the gym,
working out, fitness.
I know my mom didn't have the confidence
to even walk in the gym.
Okay, she wanted to lose weight, she wanted to be healthy,
but she didn't have the confidence.
She didn't believe in herself.
She didn't think she was worthy enough.
So now you have someone that in her 70s still says
losing weight wasn't possible because she was waiting
for the confidence to then feel good about herself
to just go in the gym and it became this like vicious cycle.
So instead of just saying, okay,
we'll just go to the gym, feel the fear and do it anyway,
come up with the steps, stepping process.
So you want confidence to feel good about yourself
to go to the gym?
Okay, the end goal is the gym.
Now, what do you do?
Make it binary.
Tomorrow I put my shoes by my bed.
That's it?
Did you do it? Yes or no?
And now you create this plan, this action plan
around the thing that you're trying to do so that every day
you don't allow your negative mindset,
the voice in your head that's saying, you're not worthy,
you're not good enough, you don't let it take over,
you don't want it to go onto autopilot.
And that's what I was doing for eight years.
My entire life was autopilot because every time I wanted
to do something, that mindset was coming in saying,
well, you don't have the confidence,
you are not good enough, who do you think you are?
And at Quest, because we were growing so quickly.
We grew at 57000%.
And so I didn't have the luxury to A, slow down.
I didn't have the luxury 'cause our house was on the line.
I didn't have the luxury just stop and say,
I don't know how.
And I don't have the confidence to do that.
So when I found myself walking into a boardroom
where let's say there's 10 guys with way more business
experience than me, the insecurity comes flooding, right?
That I don't have the confidence to walk into the room.
The imposter syndrome comes front and center.
Now the question is,
how on earth do you still walk in the room?
What do you do?
How do you know that actually, you know what?
I don't have as much experience than everyone in the room.
It's not even like, I'm just like putting myself down.
I actually don't have the experience that everyone else does
in this room so how do I keep showing up
if I don't have the confidence?
That's what radical confidence is.
And so what are those tools like I'm imagining walking
into that board room, feeling insecure,
you have a couple choices.
You can act as if and put on front and pretend
that you're on their level which is very transparent.
Or there's the opportunity to acknowledge to yourself like,
hey, I'm like maybe not at this level yet,
I still have to walk into this room,
like how do I manage that?
And you can come in and say, listen, this is who I am,
like I don't have your experience but I'm here.
That requires the level of self esteem as well
to be able to say that, to admit that weakness
and part of your kind of process here is about
like acknowledging your own weaknesses
rather than repressing them or pretending they don't exist.
It's like bring them to the surface,
be in relationship with them so you understand
what they are which gives you an opportunity
to then work on them and kind of get to the other side.
Yeah, exactly.
And to your point, there's no way I would've had the guts
to tell people I'm not at your level yet like,
the instinct is to just pretend like, go in,
pretend that what you're doing,
but that's just too crippling sometimes.
And so I actually took this from my husband,
have the identity of the learner.
So now if you've got the identity of the learner,
instead of being the identity of I know what I'm doing,
I've got this, I'm the head of shipping, I'm Tom's wife,
I'm the co-founder, hat didn't help.
Just 'cause I was the co-founder of company
didn't mean that I actually knew what I was doing
or I was confident to walk into a boardroom.
So if you adopt the identity of the learner,
now when you walk into a boardroom, how do you think I feel?
I'm like, oh, I'm gonna learn in this room.
When I go into a situation where someone's saying something
that I don't know, I was like, oh yeah, please explain
'cause I don't understand that but now as a learner,
I thrive off learning.
Now if I fall to my knees and I make a mistake
or a catastrophic mistake, as the learner,
I don't take that as a dent to my ego, I just say,
oh my God, great, now I can learn from this failure.
That's the core of the growth mindset which is to approach
every situation and outcome as a positive
because if you succeed, then you can learn
from how you got to that place.
If you fail, you can deconstruct what went wrong
and it's all good either way.
Exactly, which takes all of that kind of pressure
out of the whole thing.
But it requires you to really strip your ego away
out of the whole thing as well.
Yes and that's-
That's tricky.
That is super tricky 'cause my ego used
to steer everything and so, there was actually one day
where Tom had heard that I was getting people reaching out
asking me to do speaking gigs.
And I just kept saying now I was like, I'm so petrified.
So why would I ever do that?
That looks like so hard, it's tech inducing,
like I've seen Tom do it.
I've seen incredible, like just amazing speakers
and I was just like, that's not me, I'm terrible.
And so I kept saying no.
So one day Tom being very honest with me comes to me
and he's like, so babe, just wanna point out that right now
you say your goal is impact but you actually right now
you're not acting in accordance because you keep saying
no to these speaking gigs.
No pressure, have the life you want but as your husband,
as your committed partner, we trust each other
to be honest with each other.
So he just said, right now your actions are not aligning
with your goals.
So I actually had to sit back and I was like, okay,
my goal is impact, I do understand that getting on stage
is gonna impact people.
Okay, yes.
Why on earth am I saying no?
It's the ego, the ego doesn't wanna be embarrassed, right?
The voice in my head to saying Lisa,
people are gonna laugh at you.
Lisa, you're not as good as Tom like
it's been there to protect me, right?
It's like, don't do it, don't do it, for the love of God,
don't do it.
And so, in that moment I was like, oh,
all I have to do now with no judgment is decide
what's more important to me, my ego or my goals?
And if I can just decide, it starts with a decision,
I'll say this easy, just starts with a decision.
If I decided which I did, I was like,
my goals are more important.
I was like, great, now at least I've made the decision.
How on earth do I public speak?
Because again, it's one thing saying you're gonna do it
and another thing to actually do it.
So I sat back and I came up with a plan and the plan was,
the strategy was listen to your negative voice
'cause the negative voice used to hold me back.
But I was like, what if just like your husband,
is trying to warn you something?
He's trying to give you a signal?
So I sat back and I said, what is it trying to warn you?
Okay, just listen to it.
It's saying like, oh my God, you're so fearful,
you can't even say yes.
So I was like, okay, I can't even say yes to a speaking gig,
how do I overcome that?
Oh, hang on, they actually reach out to my team first
and it's my team that tell me.
So I'm just gonna tell my team next time,
just say yes, don't check with me, okay, great.
Now I've overcome that fear, what's the next thing
the voice in your head is saying, you're not as good as Tom.
You're gonna go on stage, Lisa, you're gonna bomb.
All right, so maybe she's right.
This critic in my head, maybe she's right,
maybe she can coach me.
So I was like, all right, turn the critic into a coach,
I can do that.
What is she saying?
Get prepared, that's what she's saying.
So I'm like, oh, she wants me to prepare.
Okay, great.
So now I just lay out, how am I gonna prepare?
What does that look like?
Because the voice in my head is very scared.
So number one, I'm going to have someone coach me
on how to do a speaking gig
'cause I've never done it before.
Who do I know my husband, great, let me book time with him.
Number two, how am I gonna read it out loud?
Okay, I'm gonna read it to him, that's one person.
Then I'm gonna read it to my team, that's 20 people.
And I literally sat there and wrote a game plan
so that every time I woke up the next day,
I was like, what do I do today?
It wasn't, how do I feel,
it was, what do I do?
And so, that was how I started to process the fear,
not listening to it, telling my ego to calm the hell down
and then still show up.
Yeah, it's a function of preparation but self-esteem
being the driver of confidence and self-esteem being driven
by performing esteemable acts on behalf of others
and yourself, the path really is setting up
these stepping stones along the way such that
when you get to that stage or you're gonna drop in
on that wave or you're gonna, whatever it is,
walk into the gym, you've already done enough legwork
in lower stakes environments that next step to the thing
that once scared you doesn't feel as intimidating
as it once was so practicing your speech in the mirror,
sharing it with a friend, being open to feedback,
doing it in front of two people and then three people
and then memorizing it and then doing it to a camera
and then having the gall to watch yourself on like
all of those things are very low stakes but are so important
in terms of the ramp up.
So that way it's not like, oh, I'm going from nothing
to walking on this TEDx stage, right?
Like there's a whole battery of interim stages
that prepare you.
Yeah, exactly.
And then even just, you said the walking on the stage,
that was so petrifying to me 'cause even
with all the preparation, I was like,
how do you actually walk on stage?
Like when you are as scared as I was, I was like,
I may be prepared but I worried as soon as I got
to the steps and I saw the audience, I would freeze.
So again, I allowed the voice in my head to talk and say,
Lisa, you don't wanna freeze like, oh my God,
people will laugh at you.
And I was like, okay, what tools do I have
to my ability that I can use to help me get on stage?
Because to me, my goal wasn't to be amazing on stage,
it was like, just actually do it.
You said that you were going to and do it.
That becomes the self-esteem part, right?
It's like I was holding my self-esteem to,
am I the person that shows up?
And so even if I bomb, at least I did it
and that's why I kept telling myself
but how long do I just show up on stage?
And so I just literally sat there and I was like,
okay, what are the tools that I can use
to help encourage me?
And I thought about the kids, do you have kids?
Hm-hm.
Did you ever give them a cape when they were kids?
I don't think so.
No, capes weren't my kids' things.
Okay, have you ever given a cape to a kid
and seen what they do?
Sure, I have seen that, of course.
Okay, they put their fist in the air, right?
And they're like, act like Superman or like,
I love Wonder Woman.
And I was like the power of clothes,
the power of something like that to a kid takes them
from being the kid to then actually them believing
they're a superhero.
So why don't we do that as adults?
It's such a great like mind hack.
And so I was like, what could that be for me?
And so I love Wonder Woman and so I was like,
oh, what if I got a Wonder Woman necklace?
So you see it here.
Yeah, yeah.
And so what I started to do is like, okay,
I've got my little item that is like the self signaling part
but I also know that you need to create a habit.
So every time I put it on, I was like,
well, how do I reinforce that I feel like Wonder Woman
when I put it on?
So I came up with a strategy that for about a month
'cause they say 30 days is what you have to do, right?
To create a habit.
So I kept putting on every day for 30 days
and every day I put it on, I was like, you're a badass
like Wonder Woman.
You're a badass like Wonder Woman.
And so, what I was doing was repeating that enough
that I was creating a habit.
So that before I got on stage,
I put on my Wonder Woman, necklace.
I have my hair braided.
I have on these big watch and cuffs and stuff-
That watch is gigantic by the way,
which is that way on your wrist.
I know, people are just like that watch is wearing you.
But all of these things are very deliberate,
I don't do this by accident because I can get
in my own head and so I literally think of ways
that I can overcome the way that I naturally am.
I don't beat myself up by having the negative thoughts,
I don't beat myself up fearing going on stage,
I just don't allow that to stop me.
Yeah it reminds me of this idea of the alter ego
like David Goggins becomes Goggins or James Lawrence
becomes the Iron cowboy.
And it's a way of putting on that sort of superhero costume
in whatever way, shape or form serves you.
It's also the idea that this guy, Todd Herman,
who's been on my podcast before who wrote a whole book
about this, "The Alter Ego Effect".
You probably-
I haven't actually read it but I know it's from him.
Yeah I mean, that's like right up the alley
of exactly what you're talking about which is creating
a little bit of distance between your fear
and what you're trying to achieve by armoring yourself
in something that allows you to kinda transcend
those insecurities and step into something greater.
Yeah, I love that and also I actually feel
a chemical change.
Like I start to feel more powerful as I like kinda suit up,
as I do my hair, as I put my jewelry on.
And so that power of like having these symbols,
I also find the beauty and the reverse.
So some days I'm going really hard for the business,
it's a grind.
It's you're facing problems all day, every day
and you're having people and just feel overwhelmed,
in those moments, I feel very hard like I can feel myself
toughen and I've got gut issues.
And so I recognize having massive like anxiety
or like stressful days isn't good for my health.
And so what tools am I going to use in moments of that?
And so usually it's like, I'll get a hug for my husband,
he normally does it.
The problem is sometimes when you're that elevated
in like emotion or you're angry or you're just like
really hard that day, a hug isn't something that you need.
And so I was like, oh, what if I do the opposite?
What if I undo myself, so what if I undo my braids,
my jewelry put on something that makes me feel soft.
So I have these surprise, surprise,
Wonder Woman fluffy pajamas and I unwind when I'm trying
to change the chemicals in my body,
I know what I can reach for.
So I take off the jewelry, I take down the hair
and then I put on something soft that makes me feel soft
so that I can then embody the softness and then I can go
get the hug from my husband and then usually eat my dinner.
But I won't eat my dinner if I'm all tired hard.
So I need those strategies in order to help me prevent,
take care of myself.
And the gut issues are, excuse me,
like some form of dysbiosis,
like what is the diagnosis there?
And there's a whole journey there, yeah.
Yeah.
So 10 years as Quest was growing, my identity was tied
to being the person that always showed up.
So I was so fearful of slipping backwards
into being a supportive wife's stay at home
and because I loved what I was doing at Quest.
I was just on the grind every day.
And I thought back then, especially back then,
I think it was definitely like how many hours do you work?
Well, how many hours do you work?
It was like, the pride was in the amount
of hard work you do.
And so, at the time I thought of myself as the more hours
I put in, the more validation I would get,
the more pats on the back I would get from other people
'cause I didn't feel good about myself, so I was being like,
I was thriving off the validation I was getting
from other people.
So for 10 years, I stopped all of,
I draw as like my hobby with art.
I stopped all of that, I stopped all of my self care.
I was very negative on myself, very hard on myself.
I thought sleep was the last thing people needed.
I also had a very unhealthy relationship growing up
with food, I saw my mom borderline anorexic
and then turned into clinically obese.
And so I had a very unhealthy relationship with food.
So you put all that together, I started getting sick a lot.
I didn't realize 70% of your immune system
is carried in your gut.
So I was not replenishing my gut with any fats or carbs
'cause I thought those were bad.
Doctors were giving me antibiotics and it got to the point
where I was taking antibiotics probably
four to five times a year.
But you do that-
Of course, just making it worse and worse
and you're just basically annihilating your whole microbiome
every time you do that.
Everything and I was doing that probably,
started off with an unhealthy relationship with food
for like, let's say period of 15 years.
And it became so cliche and it ended up being the best thing
that ever happened to me but as we're building Quest,
Tom and I used to take drives around Beverly Hills
in our really crappy car
and it was like the moments where we would dream.
When things were getting very hard,
we would dream about when Quest got successful,
what we would do and it would really help us
get over the hard days.
Flash forward Quest becomes a billion dollar company,
we actually get to buy the house in Beverly Hills.
It's like the dream freaking come true.
And I'd always dreamed, I'm a 90s gal, I love hip hop.
So I'd always said to Tom, I really wanted a waterfall
in our house so I could twerk through it
with a bowl of champagne and do a 90s hip hop video for him.
And so, that was like the fun dream that we always had.
Cut two, we actually get the house,
we actually get the waterfall
and I have a bottle of Dom Perignon in my hand.
As cliche as it sounds, in that moment,
I took a swig of champagne, like that,
my gut felt like it erupted.
That was six years ago, I'm still suffering.
So just to give context the day, the actual day
and why I say that's the most beautiful thing
is it just taught me. Success is nothing
if you don't have your health.
And thankfully I actually learned that very early on
in my success.
And so that was very much a learning lesson for me
of how to take care of myself and then how to make sure
that is the most important thing that I focus on
because throughout Quest, I wasn't focusing
on the self care part of it.
And so it was definitely a mix and then in hindsight,
it was the fact that I had leaky gut, I had SIBO.
So SIBO was so catastrophic to me, so intense,
I couldn't stand up for longer than five minutes at a time.
My gut had actually protruded out since you could see it,
like it was almost like the reverse pregnancy
and that was for at least a year I could only eat
about four ingredients.
I couldn't even put pepper on my food, that's how bad I got.
I was about 20 pounds lighter than you see me now.
Hair had fallen out, nails were brittle.
It was really bad, it was really hard.
And so, in all of that, it definitely put everything
into perspective very early on in my life.
And how did you see yourself to the other side?
Like you're doing okay now,
yeah like you're not having flareups.
I do every so often.
So I realize if I work too much, I do.
If I'm stressed too much, I do.
If I'm not paying attention to my food,
I still have to ask restaurants what oils they use
because I can't have blended oils.
I still kinda kind of do a loose SIBO diet
because anytime I have things like onion and garlic,
it just does a little flare up.
Right, right, right.
And so it has been incredible journey and an improvement
but in this story as well, the beauty in it
is that for the first year I kept blaming the doctors.
It was a doctor's fault,
they shouldn't have given me antibiotics.
And so because I was blaming the doctors,
I was looking to them to help me.
And so I was like, oh, what pill should I take?
What diet should I do?
I literally was looking for them
and every time they made a suggestion,
I would just blindly follow them.
And what I realized over time in that story
that I told earlier about being falling to the floor,
realizing I am my own hero,
why do I wait for other people to save me?
If I actually flipped that mentality
and I actually said to myself, Lisa, you can save yourself.
What would that look like, just ask yourself the question,
what would that look like?
And with my gut and health, I started to realize
I had given my power away.
I was blaming the doctors and in truth Rich,
I was the one that swallowed the antibiotics.
I was the one that when the doctor said
we probably shouldn't give you this many antibiotics,
not once that I ask, why?
Not once that I go home and Google the negative side
of taking too many antibiotics.
So if I could take ownership over that,
the beautiful thing is now I've taken my power back
and I can now fix myself.
Right, you have agency in that context which brings up
this idea or this conflict or tension between intuition.
Like my body is telling me that I should do this
versus expert advice or appeal to authority.
Like I'm just going to give up my agency,
these doctors know best I'm gonna follow them,
which you did for a while.
But at some point there's a validation of the intuition
that you have about what's right for yourself.
And I think trying to find that balance between the two,
like we should listen to our doctors,
they probably know more than what we know
about like this thing that I'm suffering from.
At the same time, we don't wanna mute, the body doesn't lie.
It's giving us signals all the time, how do you find that
balance to know what's in your best interest?
It's so true, 'cause that's a really good point
thank you for saying that because I don't think
that we should just not listen to experts.
It's like, look, experts are experts for a reason-
Right, well, we're in a period of time right now
where it's very fashionable to not listen to experts.
Yeah, it is.
I have the duality and most of the things that I do and say,
it's like it a bit of both.
It's like listen to the expert, hear them out
and then assess whether that actually sits right with you,
if it doesn't, why not?
Like ask yourself the questions, I blindly follow doctors.
So that's where I go taking the expert's advice,
listen to it maybe even trying it out.
So you know what?
This doesn't feel right but maybe I'll give it a shot.
I'll give it a shot for two days and then just assess.
But in that, because I was so blindly following it,
I realized that didn't work.
And so what I did is take, I took full ownership and I said,
okay, if this is all my fault, quote, unquote,
if I am my own hero, if I can actually change this,
what would it look like?
And I just started saying, take inventory.
So for instance, I was like, I was sleeping like 10 hours
and I was waking up exhausted.
And so the doctors were like, oh, you're probably fine
with no real advice.
So I'm like, okay, what would full ownership look like here?
It would be assess your own sleek patterns.
So I bought an Oura Ring.
I also bought one of those continuous glucose monitors.
And I just took an assessment of what I ate that day,
what time I ate, what my bowel movement was like,
what my glucose levels were when I ate what it was,
when I didn't eat, what it was like when I was sleeping.
What I started to notice was there was a correlation
between when I was waking up in the middle of the night,
my Oura Ring, which I didn't realize I was waking up,
I was just like losing a lot of REM sleep.
I could notice correlation between that
and my blood sugar levels dropping.
And so in the middle of the night I was dropping to like 40.
And so I was like, oh, okay, well that probably explains why
I'm tired, what can I do differently?
And I would just take inventory and it's like,
okay, Lisa, what are you gonna do is you're gonna maybe
have some carbs later on in the evening.
Does that make a difference?
All right, Lisa, you're gonna actually, people say fasting,
instead of blind listening to everyone saying fasting,
try it yourself.
Do one hour before bed, then do two hours before bed,
then do three hours and actually see how you feel.
And in that assessment, I was listening to my intuition,
I was testing it out, I was still listening to experts
but then I was making the conclusions for myself.
And then in that I realized,
oh, three hours for me was the magical time.
You eat three hours before bed, it gives you time
for your body to digest, you don't wake up
with a stomach upset but you also don't have crashes
in the middle of the night.
And that was all me figuring it out because I took the time,
I took the ownership and then I just took the judgment away.
That's interesting.
So your fasted blood glucose would go down to 40
in the middle of the night and the inference is that
that was damaging your body's ability
to get into the deep sleep state?
Yeah.
It's super interesting, I've played around,
I wear a Whoop and I have continuous glucose monitor
as well and it is interesting the relationship
between sleep and your body's ability to metabolize glucose.
Yes, like I didn't even realize and also like,
even the opposite I was eating right before bed
'cause I was like, well, at least you got gut issues,
you can't not feed your gut.
Like it was and then I was like, I was waking up
with the worst stomach pains and then it was like,
why am I waking up with the worst stomach pains?
And then I'd realize my body didn't have time
to digest its food, right?
So it was just like sitting heavy in my gut.
So while my husband can literally eat a donut
before he goes to bed and he's fine
like that would have a massive different impact on me.
And so when you also hear about experts, it's like,
well, where are they coming from?
Whose studies are they doing?
And even just being a female, that's like the new thing
that I'm figuring out is that I did ketogenics
and keto worked wonders for me for a short period of time
but my husband can do keto diet for a year and he's great.
And what I realized was that I was blindly listening
to experts and studies without actually even looking myself
to see where the studies done on women
because it all makes a difference with a female cycle
and that sort of thing, so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I like the ownership that you took
over the whole thing though,
that's good.
Thank you.
The other thing we gotta touch on is the people
pleasing thing.
This is something that I've battled with for a long time.
I was living my life in a certain way for many years
as a result of my basic inability to honor myself
in some regard or to look inward enough to know
what it would look like if I was to honor myself
and you have your version of that story,
you've transcended that pattern.
But I think this is something that affects a lot of people
on a spectrum and I think there's a lot of people
who aren't even aware that they're sort of relinquishing
their agency over their own life because they're
in a situation where that's just sort of expected
in terms of like how you live your life
which is kind of the situation you were in earlier on.
It's such a tricky conversation, you're right.
Like in the sense of, I actually really care about people.
And so yes, do I wanna please people? Yes.
Do I wanna please my husband? Yes.
And so it was very hard for me to think through
and write out what that can look like 'cause I don't think
it's one or the other, I don't think it's like,
well, you shouldn't people please and do you
and don't care what other people.
It's like that didn't sit well with me but I do care.
So how do I be the person that still really cares
but doesn't allow that to dictate how I show up
and what I do because that was the problem with me
for those eight years where I was staying at home.
It's like, I wanted to please my husband,
I wanted to be a good Greek wife,
I wanted to be a good Greek wife that my dad was proud of
but it held me where I was because I started to have
my identity built around the people pleasing part of it
so now if I stop doing it, who was I?
And so I think that can be really crippling
for a lot of people and it makes you act and show up
in ways that don't actually align with who you wanna be.
And so for me, it was like a fine line between,
okay, I really do want to please my husband,
I want him to be happy but where does it go to them
now become detrimental to who I want to be?
And the transition where I went from being
the supportive wife that was taken care of every need
that he had into being an entrepreneur
and an equal business partner, we had to talk about that
because I was so trying to do both, right?
You want to be there for the person
and you want to please them and you wanna make them happy
and you wanna show up in your business.
And I don't know about how you felt but it was like,
I couldn't do both well at all or either well at all.
Well, first of all, you have to have some recognition
that you're not living in alignment with the person
you wanna be.
So there's that piece and then there's the piece
of figuring out how to communicate.
Well, I think what, let me back up.
I think when you're in that state,
there's not a lot of self-reflection, right?
Because you're like, you're pleasing other people
and this is your MO, right?
So you're not looking inward so you're not really gauging
that disconnect between the person you wanna be
and the role that you're fulfilling until sort of the heat
gets turned up and then you become unhappy
and then you're confused, why am I unhappy?
I'm doing all these other things.
So there has to be some kinda like inflection point.
And then there's the piece around, how do you communicate
around that to kinda step out of the role
that you're playing and find a better, healthier one.
That is so true, 100% 'cause you're right,
I didn't even realize that that's what I was doing.
So sitting there having the reflection of does this,
who do I wanna be?
Who do I wanna show up as every day that makes me feel good,
that gives me the life that I want?
And then maybe it's even just taking account like
you just sit back with no judgment and take account
of your week and it's like, oh, I woke up
and I made my husband coffee.
And then I did the laundry for him and then Ryan it's like,
how many of those were for you?
And maybe that becomes the first part of it
in just self-assessing where your time and energy is going
because you may not realize that you're doing it
because you're an autopilot.
So actually I think that's a beautiful place to start
and then recognizing how it can hold you back
on what you're trying to do and then I use the words,
does it serve you, right?
So if you've got your goal, if you've got that idea
of who you want to be and then you take the inventory
of your day and then say, does this act serve this person
that you wanna be?
And then if the answer is no, how do you communicate that
with the people in your life?
That was really hard for me because with my husband,
I had told him I wanted four children.
And so here I was, I was a stay-at-home wife taking care
of him every single need he had to the point where
he would get home from work, his dinner was waiting for him.
He'd wake up in the morning, his gym clothes
right there waiting next to his bed.
He'd put his gym clothes on, I would hand him his key.
I mean, I'm talking every ounce of thing that he needed
and this was a decision we made together.
If I told my wife, I wanted her to put my gym clothes out,
she would just look at me like, are you insane?
And I know, the funny thing is now I laugh at it
but I was the one that actually said that
because at the time the decision was he was gonna go
and make money for movies and we had just read an interview
with Steve Jobs who said he doesn't spend even an ounce
of his time making decisions of things that don't matter.
Like same black t-shirt every day, that whole thing.
Exactly.
So that's what we did.
I was like, oh, that makes sense.
Babe, I'll make every decision for you outside of business.
That way we can expedite the business side of it
and we can hopefully make more money in a shorter period
of time and now we can go make movies.
So that's why I decided you wake up, your clothes are there.
You go to work, I hand you a lunch bag.
Like I did everything.
And so then flash forward-
You slowly disappear in the process of doing that.
So then exactly, you then you do 100%
and then Quest grows 57000%, I realized how much
I loved business and I was trying to juggle both.
Now in that I was just not doing anything well.
And so that became the point of, well, who do I wanna be?
What do I actually wanna do?
And I realized I loved entrepreneurship.
I love being challenged.
I love showing myself what I'm capable of.
One day, not knowing something, not having a skill set
and then facing that and then trying and finally succeeding
just lit me up.
And so I had to sit down and communicate that with Tom
and a big part of that was A, showing your partner respect
that I was the one changing.
And I had to be honest with that.
It's like, yes, I was this person
and now I am the one changing.
So having the respect to show them.
Then number two, I was like, I know my husband wants me,
he wants like me to be happy.
So I need to express how unhappy I was
'cause I never told him.
And so I need to express how unhappy I was for eight years
and then express him how this is making me happy.
And then I need to give him the grace to be honest
about how he feels.
And so in that I said, babe, I was profoundly unhappy,
I've now found myself but I love you more than sorry,
I love you more than life itself
but I no longer wanna put your clothes out.
I no longer wanna clean with you,
in fact, I freaking hate it.
Still means I love you.
Doesn't change how I feel about you but I absolutely hate
what I'm doing at home.
And so, I don't wanna do your laundry anymore.
And so his response was-
It's not an unreasonable request.
You're right but he was just like,
look, what kinda husband would I be that I would put laundry
ahead of your happiness?
So he was like so look, if you don't do the laundry
and I have to go work to work commando,
then I'll go to work commando.
And then we joke but then literally like five weeks later
or something, I didn't do the laundry for about five weeks.
And he's like, babe, I'm out of underwear.
So I'm going to work commando with no underwear on.
And I was like, all right, bye, thanks.
But that's an actual true story
and that was because we communicated,
I was very open about how I felt and where I was in my life.
I gave him this space to also tell me how he felt
and he was honest.
And he's like, look, of course,
I love you taking care of me.
Like what crazy person wouldn't love the fact
that they don't have to think about their food
and their clothes and all of that?
So it's going to be difficult but the transition
is gonna be difficult.
So do you mind just bearing me with me over this transition?
And so I was like, no, what if we actually have a process,
I'm gonna wean you off me being the stay at home wife.
So you're used to me doing it seven days a week.
Next week, I'm gonna do it six.
Then the week after that, how do you feel
if I just do it five?
And then the week after that, I'm just gonna do it four
and then I'm gonna do it for three days a week.
That way, it's a slow transition and you don't feel like
I've just abandoned.
He's like, actually, that sounds really nice.
Thank you for that.
So I showed him, I was being considerate.
He was now being on board with the transition
and it ended up like he just supported me
and it became like this beautiful moment where we were able
to really show up for each other.
And then the last piece of everything
that I've just laid out is the grieving part.
He had to grieve the wife that I was and I had to grieve
the wife and mother I thought I was going to be.
So what I mean by that is I decided that I no longer
wanted children.
Now, my husband really wasn't, he was just like,
if you really want children, like he,
it wasn't as big a deal to him.
But I realized I loved business so much,
so much that I had to process whether I wanted children.
I talk about that in the book, how I processed it
and I came to the conclusion that I didn't,
actually loved my life and I didn't want children.
And so even talking to him about that,
I decided I didn't want children but that didn't mean
there was a part of me
that didn't desperately want children.
And so I just had to be honest with myself that
just because we make one decision in life,
that can be beautiful, it doesn't mean that we're not upset
and heartbroken that we've had to leave another life behind.
And I think it's important to address it
and then maybe mourn and grieve it and that's what I did.
I still today, which I still today would love to see
little Tom running around, have a daughter that could like
I could help build like a strong mindset that I never had,
I could get excited over it.
So I knew that just because I didn't want children
or like I actually wanted children,
the only thing I wanted more than children
was to not have children.
So I had to give myself the grace to grieve
the idea of being a mother.
I had to give Tom the grace to grieve the idea
that we weren't gonna have children.
And then we were able to overcome it that I can actually
say it with total honesty and clarity that,
yes, it's still heartbreaking but it literally holds no tie
to my heart anymore.
Well, it's also a situation where everybody's gonna have
a lot of opinions and judgments.
Yes, oh my God, just so-
And you have to be prepared to be on the receiving end
of everybody questioning that or having their idea
around that.
Yes and actually going back to the people pleasing
subjects, my mom told me growing up my entire life,
even when I got married,
I want nothing more in life than to be a grandmother.
Those words actually came out,
Now I had then decided I wasn't gonna have kids.
So I had to tell her and I knew she would devastated,
I knew I'd break her heart and so how do you make sure
that you still hold true to who you are and what you want
in life knowing that you are about to hurt someone?
To your point, you have to stand firm
and really ground yourself in your decision
before you tell anyone else, because to your point,
people are gonna come to you.
They're gonna try and persuade you.
They're gonna try and degrade you.
They're gonna try and tell you why you are wrong.
And so, how do you stay firm without being like a bully
in the China shop that's like, don't you talk to me
like that, I've decided not to have kids 'cause again,
that doesn't help my relationship with my mom either.
So how do you do it with grace?
How do you show up and communicate that without giving up
or backtracking on this decision that is really aligned
with who you wanna be?
Right, so how do you do it?
Like how'd you drop the bomb?
I did it with utter respect.
So with my mom originally, I was like, mom,
I know that you really want grandchildren.
I've decided and I tried to do exactly what I did with Tom,
'cause it worked with Tom.
So I was, I'm just gonna explain to her that
it fills my heart and I really love it.
But I realized that the very next time she kept asking,
when you're gonna have kids?
I'm like, I just told her like literally,
a couple of weeks ago, I just told her
that I'm not having kids and she still asks me.
Yeah, it was dismissed from that compartment of the brain.
Yeah, exactly.
So I was like, okay, it's just the reality,
she doesn't want to hold onto so I think she's hoping
that it was a phase in my life.
And so, I just needed to be firm in talking to her
about it openly but the other part was,
I actually said to her mom, can you please stop asking me?
I know why and I know it comes from a good place,
that's another thing, making sure people don't feel like
they're being attacked.
Like mom, I know this is coming from a good place.
And I know that you are asking me because you hope
that maybe I'm gonna change my mind
and that hope is maybe giving you a feeling
that makes you feel good.
But I actually don't wanna give you false hope
and you asking me actually makes me feel like
you're dismissing the decision I've made.
And that was the moment she dispersed into tears.
And that was, I think the recognition that she was like,
okay, I am not able to persuade you and you've just told me
that trying to persuade you is actually hurting you.
So as your mother, of course, I will respect it.
And look, that doesn't mean that other parents
are gonna react like that, right?
It doesn't mean that other people are gonna give you
the grace in the decision you make.
Part of the calculus and not having kids
that you talk about in the book is just getting honest
with the fact that like, you both love your life
and what you're doing and you love business
and Tom having the recognition that he didn't wanna be
an absentee father, that if he was gonna be a father,
he wanted to be the kind of father that would be
in alignment with his values.
And that would create a situation that perhaps was untenable
because of putting conflict these two ideas
which I think is a really that, I mean, it takes honesty
and vulnerability to like admit that but to then say,
so we're gonna make this decision fine.
Although I would say to you, I think you guys work too hard.
Tom's working 120 hours a week.
Like I understand he's passionate about what he's doing
and that's cool.
And you don't have kids and more power to you,
you should do whatever you wanna do.
But like that's intense, man.
It is and it's one of these as long as,
the second it starts to get in our relationship,
like interfere with our relationship, I will speak up.
But if he's working 120 hours a week, how could it not?
Like that's basically all waking hours twice.
Yes, exactly.
So we sit down and again, I'm the one that waves the flag.
So for Monday to Friday, when he wakes up,
usually he's outta bed before I am.
And so, I kiss him good morning, my kettle is boiled, right?
So I know he's thought about me and then we typically
just have business meetings.
And then to the end of the day, I may not see him,
I may not interact with him until he gets into bed.
So that's on Monday to Friday, he may get into bed,
now look at the end of the day,
I want my husband to feel fulfilled.
'Cause if he's not fulfilled,
he's not bringing his best self to the relationship.
So if he finds joy in working that much, I support him.
I support him until it becomes detrimental.
So for instance, to your point, where do you find time?
I'm very busy.
I'm very passionate about what I do as well.
So I don't feel neglected in any way
or I don't feel like he's an absent husband
but because I'm on the tour with my book
and it's been so busy.
In fact, literally yesterday, yesterday, Rich, I text him
and I said, babe, I just looked at our calendar.
We haven't connected for two weeks.
I just looked at our calendar, your mom arrives tomorrow.
So his mom arrives today.
And I was like, and then she's here for two weeks
and then I go straight to England to carry on my book tour.
So there's four weeks now that we're not gonna hang out
and actually have quality time
'cause I I'm all about quality time.
I'm not about how much time, it just has to be quality.
And so I just identified, oh,
if we don't change something right now,
if he continues down the 120 hours to your point
of working this much, now it becomes detrimental
to our relationship and I ain't having that.
So I text him yesterday and he's like,
okay, let's make time.
And so now it's like, I feel very confident
that he's going to make sure that he's doesn't have, sorry,
that he make sure that he has time for us to connect.
And in those moments that 120 hours don't sit well with me
because he's not gonna be with me if he has to do 120 hours.
But other than that, like I know who I'm married.
And that was another thing.
Like I've seen so many couples that they think
that if you've got a ring on your finger
or you've got children, that it changes the person.
So I just go into it with honesty and my eyes wide open.
So to your point of what you said earlier,
when we were gonna have kids or I was assessing whether
we should have kids or not, I looked at my life and I said,
I love working, so if I had children,
what would that look like right now?
And so in that I had to ask Tom,
babe, what type of father do you wanna be?
And he said, I don't wanna be the father that's coming home
or the person that's coming home at five, six o'clock
in the evening to have dinner with the kids.
I'm so passionate about what I do that from basically
from Monday to Friday, I won't be getting up
in the middle of the night and changing their diapers
and I won't be home at 6:00 PM to have dinner.
Now I can only respect that he was honest with me.
And so, now the fact that he was honest with me,
I can take that information and then see,
is that the life that I want.
Do I want kids where my husband isn't gonna be home
at dinner every night?
Does that mean that I'm basically a single parent
from Monday to Friday?
At least I know because the amount of people
I've seen in marriages, especially when there's new kids,
where they're like my husband, I had to force him
to get up in the middle of the night.
I don't wanna be in a business where I'm forcing my husband
to do anything.
So if we can at least have the communication
with no judgment, then you can just take it for fact
before I actually have the kid and then realize,
oh, oh, you're not gonna be getting up in the middle
of the night?
I don't want that surprise.
Now knowing what type of father he's gonna be,
he said to me, on weekends, babe, of course I wanna be there
for my children.
So knowing that piece of information,
I literally said to him, so where's the time for me and you?
And that's where the realization came from where it's like,
oh, so if we do this based on what we know about each other,
based on what we know about ourselves,
this could damage our relationship
and are we willing to risk that?
And the answer was no.
Yeah, you thought through every permutation
of the whole thing and made the right decision for you guys.
So it's perfectly fine.
I just don't want Tom to have his version of your gut issues
because he is working too hard, that's all.
And that's very important to me and I actually am trying
to be a what's the word?
A good example.
So he'll say like, oh, well let's just have
the meeting at 7:00 p.m. and I'll be like,
no, babe, I'm switching off today at six.
And I'll just be like, you can come and join me,
Or like, hey, I need space,
I need to create this mental space for me.
He's definitely way like just hardcore
like he thrives off it.
And so, but as the wife, obviously I care about his health
and so making sure that we are able to do what we can
to optimize his health in any way possible.
So his sleep, his diet, all of that.
The last thing I want to get into is this transition
into being a media company.
While you were still at Quest, there was this decision
to create kinda like the in-house talk show,
I remember those early videos.
And then there's the Quest exit and now Impact Theory
and "Women of Impact" and all these shows
that you guys are doing, it's very professionally run.
You guys have both developed really large followings
of people, you put out like the highest quality content.
I mean, it's so clearly distinguished from pretty much
everything else that's out there.
Like the level of intentionality that goes into it,
the guest selection, like everything about it
is like top tier and like, is it the tip of the spear,
everybody's watching to see what you guys are doing
and then are mimicking it or copying it.
And it's cool and I think it's an amazing service
that you put out into the world for free.
So walk me through like that decision,
like after the Quest exit, there's no real urgency
to do anything like how do you find meaning?
You've achieved such tremendous success?
What is the impetus and the motivation
and the kinda value set that's driving you guys so hard,
to work so hard on this stuff and put this messaging
out into the world.
Well, first one, I wanna say thank you,
that's a huge compliment coming from you.
So I appreciate that.
So as we were building Quest, the mission part of it
became a very strong pull for me and Tom.
So for me, originally, it was help Quest to save your house
so that you don't lose your house.
And then over time, that is obviously a very fear based
thing to propel you forward.
And so over time I needed to attach to a mission.
And so we got this letter one day from this woman
really early on, she was anorexic
and she'd been in hospital, she was 40 pounds
and she was basically on her deathbed.
And she wrote us an email and said,
thank you for making Quest bars because it made me okay
with calories again.
Now having a mother who was borderline anorexic,
having unhealthy relationship with food myself,
I didn't see that coming.
I expected like the obese community,
thank you for helping me lose weight.
And then there was another letter from this woman who,
she had a type one diabetic son
and he was like four years old and she's like
every day of his life, I'm always having to follow him,
make sure he doesn't pick up cupcakes at a birthday parties
and blah, blah, blah and I feel like a terrible mother.
But he can actually have Quest Bars
and his blood sugar doesn't spike.
Thank you for making me feel like a better mom.
And I was like, oh my God,
So mission, very much over time became a big pull for me.
And so as our mission and the company grew,
that story that I said where we got the house
and it was like the dream come true, that day where like
you hear rumors that, it takes a while when you sell
a portion of a company.
So you heard rumors, it was gonna hit on one day
and so we are waiting, we're waiting,
we're like refreshing our bank account basically
and then all of a sudden the money hits
but we were tied to a mission.
So as soon as the money hit, we celebrated,
we took a selfie and we got dressed
and went straight back to work.
So as Quest just got bigger and bigger,
we realized that Quest bars were amazing for people
who had already decided they were worth it.
The people who already decided, you know what?
I'm not gonna pick up a candy bar today,
I'm gonna pick up a Quest bar.
But what about the millions and millions of people
that don't even believe they're worth it?
They are too depressed or to have too much anxiety
to walk into the gym?
How do you help those people?
And what we realized was our transformation in our lives
had become because of the mindset.
And so Tom and I said, we need to really help people
with the mind and because both of our backgrounds
were filmmaking, we both loved content, Tom was like,
well, babe, what if we build a studio and I just interviewed
the most incredible people, doctors, influences,
business people, anyone who has amazing message
to help impact people?
Now that really is like the no BS,
how do you actually create 360 wellness?
You attach the mind and the body not just the body.
So we started this show, started doing very well
and then we realized that that was the most powerful piece.
Now when you're growing and you've got business partners,
we realized that this was really where our heart was.
They wanted to focus on just the body.
So we spun that studio out into our own studio.
And so we realized that was where the people were going
to meet us in order to get the Quest bar.
Like my mom, she was clinically obese by the time
this whole story started and I was trying to throw money
at it like mom, here's the best chef.
Here's a trainer like lose and she kept saying,
I can't lose the weight, I'm too old.
I'm too old, I'm 70, I'm too old.
Diets don't work for me.
She happened to have retired just as we started
Impact Theory.
And so she started to watch Tom's content.
And as she was watching Tom's content within a year,
she lost 120 pounds.
Wow.
And she went from the person that said
she can't lose the weight, she's too old
to one day I caught her up and I'm like,
oh mom, how are you doing?
How's the health journey going?
So always tried to, about health, not weight.
She was like, well, it was really raining today.
And in my mind I was like, and here come the excuses, right?
Of why she wasn't able to maybe get in her health work out
that she said she was gonna do.
And she's like, so I got in the car and I drove
to the biggest grocery store near us and I got my Fitbit
and I walked up and down the aisles,
I did four miles and I bought an apple and I turned around
and drove back home.
Aw.
Now that is mindset right there in action.
That is showing someone how even in her 70s,
just by changing how she thought about things,
she was able to achieve whatever she wanted in life.
And so for us, the pivot really became the question
of what do we want to wake up every day and do?
We could have bought an island,
we could have bought an island but after a week
we would've been bored.
What's that mission?
What's that reason you get up every day?
And so for us now, the reason why Tom works 120 hours
is because he believes even more now in what we do.
He believes even more in what we're trying to achieve.
And so that's why you see us like if we work as hard
as we do is because we so believe in and attach ourselves
to our mission, that we hold ourselves accountable
and again, because of my health that I said,
I'm so glad it happened on that day of all days
because it taught me immediately that money and success
doesn't buy you happiness.
How you feel about your self does, that's it.
How you feel about yourself.
So do I feel healthy?
Do I feel good?
Do I have a healthy mindset?
Am I proud of myself?
Do I get up every day and fight for something
bigger than myself?
If I can keep answering those as yes
then I know I'm doing the right thing.
That's beautiful.
Just don't fall into the all this wellness
is making me unwell trap.
I know and here's the thing-
That's the thing like we're so of service
that we're actually like destroying our own lives
in the process.
And Rich, you are 100% right.
And look, it can become detrimental.
And so I'm very aware of that because of my gut issues
and I'm definitely make sure or at least not definitely
make sure I try to make sure right now especially
that I'm focusing on that, especially with Tom as well.
Good.
Final thing I want to get into and then I'll release you
to your life.
No, this has been so fun, are you joking?
Is, well, I mean, I think what we should do is round
this out with just some thoughts for people
that are at the beginning of this radical confidence journey
like what are the first steps that somebody can take?
I'm imagining the person who's watching or listening
who feels alone, who has an issue with self-esteem,
who doesn't feel deserving of good things,
who once had an ambition for what their life could be
but is now in a situation that's okay, why rock the boat
and incur that risk into your life if you don't think
that it's ever gonna work out anyway?
Like untie that knot and let's get that person
on a different mindset route towards a healthier perspective
and provide them with the beginning points of a set of tools
that could reshape how they're thinking about this
and move them in a better direction.
All right, let's do it.
So step one, I think is saying, right now are you saying
I'm gonna do this when?
So if you like, just start taking inventory, if you do,
I wanna ask you a question, what if that when never comes?
Would you still be on the path you're on now?
Like imagine this thing, would you still do what you do
every day if you knew that the, when never came?
I your answer is no, that's amazing
because now you've identified that you need to make a shift.
Now how do you make that shift?
I want them to answer the other question
is you want the confidence in order to do what?
You have to identify what that goal is, right?
So it's like, you have to recognize that you're not
on the path you wanna be.
You have to recognize now what that path
should look or could look like and that end goal.
And then you need to create a stepping stone plan
of how you're going to do it one small step at a time,
maybe you can't even do the plan yet.
Maybe you just have to take inventory of what you do
on a daily basis so you can just assess
where your life is being spent now
'cause you've said it multiple times, right?
We'll go on autopilot, we may not even know.
And then putting those step in stones
of what that looks like.
But then I would actually say,
I do tell the people around me, so sharing this new path,
this new goal with the people,
I think is gonna be very helpful for people that may not
be able to take that first step
and it doesn't have to be everyone.
And I would actually advise, only tell the people
that you actually feel are gonna support you
because right now maybe you're not strong enough
to tell people that are gonna be like,
oh my God, you're gonna do that?
'Cause everybody obviously has an opinion
and then once you've identified the steps,
now, in fact, actually I'm gonna back up,
I missed out one step.
What is your mission because you may have a goal,
you have to tie that goal to a mission
because you don't know if you're actually gonna get
to the goal and you can sure bet that on your way
to the goal, you're gonna have hurdles and obstacles
all along the way, so how do you keep moving forward?
For me, it was absolutely identifying that mission
because in everything we've been talking about,
facing the fear, facing the insecurity,
facing the negative voice, why?
'Cause people go, why would I do that?
Why would I keep moving forward?
To me, it was the mission.
Every time I doubted myself,
I had to bring myself back to that.
And so when someone's thinking about a mission,
to me it's like, what is that thing
that pulls at your heart strings?
Now once you've thought about it, actually be succinct
in what that mission is because you can't be like up
and oh, I kinda I wanna create impact.
Even that, what does that mean?
That could be like, you wanna create impact for your kid.
You wanna impact your friend?
Like how do if you're actually moving towards it or not?
So to me, I think being very succinct in that mission
is also the next step.
How do you write a mission statement?
Well, even, sorry to intervene?
No please, jump in.
I think the greater like what I'm imagining
as you're saying this is the person who is stuck
in kind of a dead end situation or just a less
than stellar situation who's thinking like,
all they're thinking about is like, this kinda sucks
but she's talking about a mission like I don't even know
what I wanna do at all.
Like I don't know how to have a mission.
Like I'm trying to imagine just a job
that's a little bit better than the one I currently have.
Right, okay thank you, that's amazing
because I think that's really freaking strong
because I think about mission now as like
it's the thing that I always go to but you are right.
How do people even know what a mission is?
Sometimes you may not know
and that's where experiments come in.
You have to give yourself the grace to see
what pulls at your heart strings because you may not know,
you may have been stuck to your point like I was
maybe been stuck for eight years, you don't even know.
Like I wouldn't have known that my mission
was to help people if I hadn't have started Quest
and been thrown into it.
So I think it becomes giving yourself the grace
to experiment.
What does that actually look like?
Take out a piece of paper and just jot down all the things
that sound good.
Like so if it was impact, let's just say
I wanna impact people.
Okay, what does that actually mean?
Well, I'm not actually sure yet.
Okay, well, write out a list of all the ways
you can impact people, go volunteer at a homeless shelter.
Maybe that's your jam.
I think most people who say they want to impact people,
what they're really saying is they want attention.
Oh, interesting.
Okay, so let's piece that.
In fact, I love that honesty and here's the thing actually,
if people listening right now can be that honest
with themselves, I think that that can be beautiful.
And the reason why I think that can be beautiful
is the next question I ask is
why do you feel like you need attention?
And then it's like, well, because I don't get attention,
I don't feel good about myself.
Right, I'm not seen.
Yeah, I'm not seen.
Okay, great.
Or I have some deep insecurity,
I feel invisible in the world or my ego is wounded
or it could be a million things.
I mean, my point in bringing that up is that
it's a little bit more of an internal search,
a deep psychological search than it is just like,
oh, these are the things that interest me
when you're drilling down to like mission
because I think we play tricks on ourselves.
We're not even honest with ourselves
about what it is that we actually want.
That's actually really true and I love that
and I think that being able to drill down just means like,
for me, it's taken the judgment away
and then just keep asking questions.
So well, I just wanna impact
'cause I wanna feel good about myself.
Okay, well, why don't you feel good about yourself
right now?
What would that look like?
Because sometimes to your point, we may not know.
And so if you can give yourself the grace,
the grace, the grace, grace, to just keep asking question
and then see where it leads you?
And then I do think trying though because sometimes
you don't know.
And so, you're like, well, I don't think really that,
that doesn't sound great.
Just give it a shot because maybe you'll be surprised.
And so, if you don't actually take action,
that's also another thing 'cause I think some people
actually will stay internal, right?
They're just like, well, I'm doing the inner work
but they're not actually putting themselves out there.
Right, the inner work has to translate
into some kinda behavioral change at some point.
Otherwise, it's just masturbatory.
Yeah, exactly.
It really is because it's kinda like the,
oh, I can't remember the phrase that people use
now where it's like, they listen to the podcast
and they read the books and so they're like,
yes, I'm in self-help but they're not taking action.
They've convinced themselves that by doing the work
or listening to the podcast or going to these events
that they're doing the work.
But if you're only looking at one piece of the puzzle,
I think that this whole other world that you're missing.
So if all you're looking at is what your actions are
and you're not internalizing it, that's a problem.
But also on the reverse,
if all you're doing is internalizing
and doing the inner work but not taking the action
to actually prove to yourself whether you can do it,
whether it feels right, whether it is pulling out
your heart strings, how are you ever gonna know?
You're gonna stay internal and to me,
the action part is such a imperative part of the process.
I think there's an epidemic of that.
You know you scroll through Instagram,
you see the inspiring quote, you listen to the podcast,
you read the book or you read the summary of the book
and then you feel like you've accomplished something.
There is a little bit of a dopamine release with that like,
oh, this was an esteemable act on behalf of myself,
I've done the work, why isn't my life any better, you know?
And, oh, well, it must be because there's this new book
that came out this week or this other podcast
that I haven't listened to.
At this point, the information is all out there, you know?
And then it becomes on you as to whether
you start practicing it.
And really getting honest with yourself
and modifying some of your behavior patterns
that are leading you astray.
1000% and that's why I also write the book,
I didn't want people to think of me being as like
anything but completely imperfect
but I'm actually okay with that.
I just keep showing up and even today,
I've just been traveling, so I've been really tired.
And so I actually put on some like socks that's-
I know you got these crazy-
I'm gonna pull off my shoes.
All right, so she believes she could-
Nice.
So she did.
Oh wow, where you did get those?
My sister actually gave me these
but I've got Wonder Woman socks.
So the point of why I'm showing you my socks right now
is because I want you to know there are moments
where I don't feel great.
There are moments where I'm tired and I'm,
you know I have doubt and I have insecurities.
And so, I just say, how do I keep showing up?
And it's okay and giving yourself the grace
that it's never one and done, it's never perfection.
It is this ebb and flow, is this ever evolving like,
oh, I used this technique, it didn't work.
What else am I gonna try?
Because to me, I don't want people to just listen
to this podcast or read the book and feel good
about themselves for an hour.
The whole point is for them to actually take the tactics
and use them in their life because I still use the tactics.
Like I said, I've got the socks on today
because I needed that extra little boost of confidence
to come to the Rich Roll Podcast.
So I just own it and I adapt and don't think
that I've always got it handled.
Yeah, I appreciate that and I appreciate
the "Women of Impact" show that you host
being so female-centric,
I think this whole kind of self-improvement internet space
is overwhelmingly too male dominated.
And with the exception of you know,
there's Brene Brown and Glennon Doyle
and there's some amazing women out there
but there aren't enough and I think it's really cool
that you're like, I'm gonna have these amazing women on,
these are the stories I'm gonna share.
I'm gonna put out this certain message for a certain
type of audience that is underserved right now.
And I think that and I just wanted to acknowledge that
as being like a powerful and important thing that you do.
Thank you, it actually comes, can I be honest?
It comes from such a selfish place.
I'm like getting in front of these women every week,
I learn and empowers me and that's part of why I do
it as well 'cause I'm like, if I'm just showing up
and these women are not impacting me,
how can I expect them to impact other people?
And so I think that we're all like a example.
And so for me, it's like, I'm always showing up flawed
and try to own it in the most honest sense possible.
And then having these guests on to kinda show
that none of us are perfect.
No one knows everything and as a female,
it's okay to own insecurities,
it's okay to talk about things but to not let it stop you.
And that's been my journey and so,
as much as I can help impact people,
you wanna talk about the mission, right?
That's what gets me out of bed every day.
Right and not stop you from engaging with Patty Jenkins
when you run into her at the airport
'cause you have a Wonder Woman symbol in the back
of your head like shaved into the back of your head
and you run into the director of "Wonder Woman".
Died, I almost died.
I had the "Wonder Woman" shave because-
Come on, that's a divinely, of course,
you were gonna run into Patty Jenkins.
So the funny thing is,
is that was another empowering piece.
So I was going to New York, it was the week of my launch
of my book and I was on my first live television show
with Tamlin Hall.
Now I've never been on live television before
so I was so scared, I was petrified.
And so I was like, all right, Lisa, you know who you are,
you don't always have to feel confident
but you do have radical confidence
which means you're gonna use the tools you need
in order to show up and go on Tamlin Hall.
And so I was like, I need the Wonder Woman logo shaved
in my head and I do it every so often.
And so I happen to have done it and then yes,
at the airport on the way back, I get a tap on the shoulder
and it's freaking Patty Jenkins.
And she's like, I just saw the "Wonder Woman" logo,
I saw your backpack has a "Wonder Woman" logo
and she's like, I just had to come and say hello.
That's so great.
It's so amazing.
Yeah, you gotta get her on your show.
Oh dude, I'm working on it, trust me.
She's a powerhouse.
She's amazing.
She's a beast, she's got a great backstory too.
Punk rock and you know, like it's a really cool like story
about like following your heart and your-
I actually dunno too much about her back story.
She has a great story.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, she would be a great guest.
You gotta get her.
I'm totally girl crushing on her.
And I'm just like, oh my God, she's so amazing.
I mean like, come on, she makes movies, directs movies
and "Wonder Woman".
It's like, am I not?
I'm like absolutely obsessed with her.
But like, that's the other thing is that I still allow
myself to play so much.
I allow myself so much to be that kid that when I fricking
meet Patty Jenkins, I lose my mind.
And I'm like, I can't believe I met Patty Jenkins.
I allow that, I want to feel joy in my heart.
I wanna be silly like that's how I keep showing up.
It's the excitement in me that keeps me going
and I think as adults, I definitely had lost that for years
and years and years.
And so I purposely cultivate it now which is why
I put the "Wonder Woman" logo,
you know my office is full of statues of superheroes
doing like these powerful moves and flying in the air.
And I've literally got like statues in my office.
We gotta get you over to Sideshow.
I know, I so wanna go.
That's that's where they make the best statues.
That's why I came in your room and I was just like,
totally like a, I was like this like Disney Land to me
right now, guys.
It's beautiful.
We'll set that up.
In the meantime, I really appreciate everything
you shared today, thank you.
Yeah, it's super inspiring.
You have such a command over the message
that you're trying to put out into the world
and it's earned through experience and I just found it
very helpful and so, I am at your service.
I appreciate everything that you're doing
and it's super cool.
And it's been fun getting to know you a little bit today
and I look forward to getting to know you
and Tom a little bit better.
Thank you, it's been such a pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
In the meantime, everybody pick up "Radical Confidence",
you can find it on Amazon or lisabilyeu.com.
radicalconfidence.com.
Yeah, got a website.
There you go.
"Women of Impact", Lisa is easy to find on the internet,
anywhere else you wanna direct people
or any kind of announcements you wanna make before
we let you go?
No, that's great.
I mean, the book is on radicalconfidence.com and my podcast,
I usually focus on the video content.
Yeah, it's more YouTube forward, yeah.
On YouTube, yeah.
I love YouTube.
You get to see like the interaction and yeah.
Cool, all right.
Well, come back and talk to me again sometime.
Definitely, thanks for having me.
Peace.
Later.
(bright upbeat music)